je vous propose de passer à à l'audition
du du jour la semaine dernière nous
avons eu plusieurs auditions concernant
les enjeux de notre présence militaire
en en Afrique avec notamment une
audition commune avec la commission des
affaires étrangères d'Hubert Vedrine et
ce matin je vous repose conformément aux
décisions du bureau de nous intéresser
aux stratégies de nos compétiteurs en
Afrique euh essentiellement donc la
Russie la Chine ou encore la Turquie qui
est comme vous le savez y étendre leur
leur influence ces stratégies sont sont
multiples sont bien entendu diplomatique
mais également sécuritaire comme le
démontre le rôle joué par le groupe de
mercenaires russes Wagner la présence
chinoise à Djibouti ou l'activisme turc
en Libye euh au travers par exemple
d'exportation d'armes typiquement on
pense au drones TB2 turc ces stratégies
au-delà d'être diplomatiques
sécuritaires elles sont également
économiques et et alimentaires euh on
peut penser à la prédiation chinoise sur
les ressources naturelles en en
contrepartie de de prêt à faible
conditionnalité ou encore à
l'instrumentalisation russe des enjeux
d'exportation des céréales ukrainiennes
vers l'Afrique où on parlait on pourrait
également en parler de l'étude récente
qui relève que l'or extrait par weegner
en Afrique aurait rapporté au kremelin
jusqu'à 2,5 milliards de dollars depuis
le début de la guerre en Ukraine ce qui
est malheureusement la preuve du bon
fonctionnement du néocolonialisme russe
les stratégies mises en œuvre par ces
compétiteurs sont enfin
informationnelles elles visent à
meudeler des opinions en Afrique comme
en Europe par l'instrumentalisation des
réseaux sociaux et de médias pour
imposer leur vision du monde trop
souvent aux intérêts de la vérité et et
au détriment également de de nos
intérêts pour nous aider à mieux
comprendre la réalité de ces influences
les stratégies mises en place ainsi que
les États africains les les plus
concernés nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui trois
chercheurs que je remercie pour leur
présence et leur disponibilité monsieur
Maxime odinet qui à ma droite donc vous
êtes chercheurs à l'IRSEM que l'on ne
présente plus dans les domaines de
stratégie d'influence et des études
russes post-soviétiques vous nous
parlerai je pense de du rôle de la
Russie notamment en Afrique à votre
droite monsieur Paul Charon qui est
également chercheur à àirsem et plus
précisément directeur du domaine
renseignement anticipation et stratégie
d'influence vous êtes un spécialiste de
la Chine et nous comptons sur vous pour
nous expliquer les opérations
d'influence chinois en en Afrique
d'ailleurs l'EM avait eu un ouvrage
remarqué à ce sujet là au niveau des
influences chinoises au niveau plus plus
large au niveau plus mondial et enfin
Jonathan Giffard Jonathan Giffard vous
êtes chercheur à l'Institut mantienne et
travaillé notamment sur la Turquie nous
serions heureux de vous entendre sur les
ressur de puissance de la Turquie en
Afrique et sur les différents relais
d'influence sur lesquels elle s'appuie
pour relayer sa politique messieur je
vous laisse la parole peut-être on peut
commencer par maximeinet sur la
Russie
très bien merci monsieur le Président
merci pour votre invitation donc
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés je
vais vous parler justement de la la
présence de la Russie en Afrique
notamment en Afrique sub-saharienne sur
laquelle j'ai travaillé depuis à peu
près 2 ans avec une approche qui est
essentiellement empirique puisqueen fait
je me suis intéressé vraiment au au
dispositifs de pratique et d'acteurs mis
en place par la Russie dans cette région
parallèlement à des recherches que
j'avais mené antérieurement sur cette
présence et ce dispositif russe tel
qu'il est fabriqué en Russie donc ça
m'intéressait de voir comment il il y
était déployé alors quel quelques
éléments peut-être ou idée principal sur
cette cette présence et influence russe
en Afrique d'abord pour vous rappeler
que le réengagement de la Russie en
Afrique qui date de de la fin des années
2000 il a très longtemps été dominé par
la coopération de défense et la vente
d'armement qui est toujours toujours un
marché essentiel pour la Russie mais on
observe depuis le le sommet
russie-afrique de Sochi d'octobre 2019
un un nouveau positionnement justement
qui est celui du d'une affirmation de la
Russie comme un prestataire de de
sécurité et un protecteur des
souveraineté africaine je vais y revenir
ainsi que un un partenaire économique
qui serait je dirais fiable et non
conditionnel même si pour le coup on
observe que le le les volumes d'échanges
entre la Russie et et l'Afrique n'ont
pas considérablement augmenté ces
dernières années même si euh voilà la
Russie reste disons à à peu près au
niveau des des pays européens pris
individuellement en matière en matière
d'échange même si c'est pas du tout les
mêmes marchés autre élément évidemment
essentiel c'est le déploiement
progressif du groupe Wagner depuis 2018
dans un certain nombre de de pays de la
région euh et puis bien entendu la
conflictualité informationnelle
considérablement accrue qui
a qui a eu lieu parallèlement justement
au déploiement de Wagner et au retrait
de la présence française dans la région
qui est en soi un élément intéressant
pour analyser justement ce qu'on appelle
les luttes informationnelles et puis
enfin toujours dans le le même ordre
d'idée on observe depuis la mort d'evgie
prigogin donc le le le le fondateur du
groupe Wagner donc mort à la fin du mois
d'août après quelques
semaines disons de de suspension à la
suite de sa sa rébellion avorté contre
le contre l'état-major des des armées
russes et bien on observe justement une
restructuration de ce que j'avais appelé
dans mes travaux la bicéphalie de la
présence russe en Afrique bicéphale
parce que elle a un seul corps mais une
une face étatique et une face non
étatique qui était justement incarnée
par Wagner mais donct on sait qu'elle
était très fortement soutenue par
l'étarus et aujourd'hui et je crois que
par exemple des pays comme le Burkina
Faso sont un un excellent exemple pour
observer ces mutations on voit queon
n'est pas revenu à une forme de
monocéphalie mais en tout cas on voit
des arbitrages très forts pour une une
tentative par le ministère de la Défense
et les services notamment le guerou mais
aussi le SVR de reprendre le contrôle
sur cette héritage justement de Wagner
en Afrique
subsaharienne un autre élément aussi
essentiel dont je voulais parler
puisqu'il concerne directement la
critique de la présence française c'est
l'actualisation et l'affirmation d'un
véritable récis stratégique qui est
celui du de la lutte contre le
néocolonialisme c'est essentiel parce
que la Russie en fait actualise par là
évidemment le le récit qui avait été
déployé par et la posture qui était
celle de l'Union soviétique en Afrique
sub-saharienne dans les années 50 et 60
donc c'est évidemment un récit à la fois
très simple mais qui raisonne énormément
auprès des sociétés africaines et qui
connaît dans le même temps une véritable
explosion
dans le discours politique russe puisque
on voit que si on prend par exemple
uniquement les discours de Vladimir
Poutine que Poutine a employé le champ
lexical du colonialisme deux fois plus
depuis l'invasion à grande échelle de
l'Ukraine qu'il ne l'a employé durant la
totalité du reste de sa présidence entre
2000 et 2022 de la même manière au sein
du Parlement russe notamment de la Doua
il y a toute une série de débats
parlementaires sur cette question de
l'anti de l'anticolonialisme si bien
qu'on observe vraiment une
restructuration dans le discours
politique russe de la critique
anti-occidentale et notamment de la
critique de la présence française en
Afrique à partir de ce récit
anticolonial qui est vraiment je crois
une une espèce de vague qui commence à
qui est déjà bien présente mais qui va
continuer de de percer et et d'être
mobilisé dans le discours russe pourquoi
parce queévidemment elle permet à la
Russie aussi de légitimer sa position
vis-à-vis ce qu'on appelle parfois
improprement le sud global mais en tout
cas euh un certain nombre d'États qui se
rejoignent en tout cas sur ce récit d'un
d'un interventionnisme délétaire
occidental
euh donc et oui et je précise évidemment
voilà que que c'est que c'est un récit
qui est d'autant plus efficace qu'il
n'est pas à
l'origine pensé par par pensé et surtout
je dirais diffusé par la la présence
russe puisque c'est un récit qui
préexiste qui est déjà très présent au
sein des sociétés africaines qui est
mobilisé par des acteurs politiques des
activistes et que la Russie cherche à
aiguillonner euh à amplifier de la même
manière qu'elle a pu le faire auparavant
et qu'elle cherche d'ailleurs toujours à
le faire vis-à-vis de certains
mouvements populistes notamment
d'extrême droite en
Europe par ailleurs et là j'en viens à à
cette dimension plus empirique l'Afrique
notamment subsaharienne est vraiment un
espace qui est très pertinent pour
étudier justement l'éventail des
pratiques d'influence et de lutte
informationnelle de la Russie puisqu'en
fait l'ensemble de l'écosystème des
acteurs qui mobilisent ces pratiques ce
soit la la diplomatie publique la
désinformation les manipulations de
l'information et bien l'ensemble de
dispositifs est déployé dans la région
et notamment dans des pays comme le Mali
la République centrafricaine et le
Burkina qui sont justement aussi ces
espaces de recomosition de la présence
russe alors il y a trois types d'acteurs
que je vais que je vais égrainer puis
après je je m'arrête là vous avez
d'abord les acteurs étatiqu russes qui
aujourd'hui deviennent de plus en plus
dominants avec d'abord des instruments
médiatiques trans nationaux RT sputnic
qu'on a qu'on a bien connu en France et
qui ont été vous le savez
suspendus par l'Union européenne à la
enfin au sein de l'Union européenne à la
suite de l'invasion à grande échelle de
l'Ukraine mais qui contrairement parfois
à à une une une idée reçu que que
j'entends ici et là n'ont pas en fait
disparu RT France qui s'appelle
maintenant RT en français existe
toujours même si c'est relocalisé à
Moscou et surtout ce sont des médias qui
cherchent de nouveaux marchés pour
compenser cette éviction des pays
occidentaux et l'Afrique subsaharienne
en fait en fait vraiment partie on voit
que la part des audiences africaines de
ces médias augmente très nettement que
les les contenus produits sur l'Afrique
sur RTE spoutnque augmentent aussi de
manière absolument considérable
aujourd'hui on estime que 30 % des
contenus qui sont diffusés et produits
par la chaîne anglophone de RT concerne
l'Afrique euh et et c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait visible aussi pour
pour spoutnck vous avez aussi euh les
acteurs de ce qu'on appelle la
diplomatie numérique c'est-à-dire en
fait la manière dont les ambassades de
Russie le ministère des Affaires
étrangères le ministère de défense
communique en ligne pour justement
atteindre aussi des audiences étrangères
et très clairement la communication
numérique des ambassades de Russie en
Afrique a vraiment évoluer depuis
l'invasion à grande échelle de l'Ukraine
avec des contenus beaucoup plus
agressifs et et plus importants aussi
sur le plan qualitatif et et quantitatif
et puis enfin vous avez un élément
central qui sont les opérations
informationnelle des unités du ministère
de la Défense russe et puis surtout des
services de renseignement et notamment
le le guou qui on le vois peu à peu
essaie de reprendre la main justement
sur toute la partie des activités
informationnelles de de Wagner que je
vais décrire brièvement maintenant euh
donc voilà la deuxième partie ce sont ce
qu'on appelle nous les
acteurs je dirais
nonoficiel semi-étatique ce que mes
collègues Kevin limonier Marie on appelé
les entrepreneurs d'influence euh ce que
moi j'appelle aussi des acteurs
adocratiques c'est-à-dire qui sont
mobilisés de manière ad hoc par l'État
russe pour justement intervenir là où
l'État ne souhaite pas s'impliquer
directement et agir de manière beaucoup
plus souple et beaucoup plus flexible
que des acteurs euh bureaucratiques
c'est évidemment euh ce qu'on a observé
avec le groupe Wagner avec son modèle à
trois dimensions que vous avez rappelé
qui est donc cette prestation de de
sécurité et cette entrepreneuriat de
violence aussi ce sont des acteurs qui
mobilisent la violence pour parvenir à
leur fin euh un acteur qui est très
présent sur le plan économique avec la
la évidemment la prédation et
l'exploitation de matières premières et
puis toute cette partie informationnelle
qui était bien incarnée autour de ce
qu'on appelle le projet larta qui est ce
projet d'usine à troll mis en place
justement par Prigogine qui était
d'abord centralisé à Saint-Pétersbourg
puis ensuite décentralisé y compris euh
dans un certain nombre de pays africains
l'un des évén enfin l'un des événements
les plus plus marquant de de de ces
agissements c'est l'affaire de gosi du
charnier de gosi dont vous avez entendu
parler puisqu'il a été il a été débunké
et et attribué à Wagner par notre
ministère des armées et ce qui est
aujourd'hui intéressant c'est qu'on voit
que il y a un espèce de relicaat de ce
de C cet écosystème d'influence
informationnel mis en place par Wagner
en Afrique puisque des actifs
informationnels par exemple des faux
comptes sur X telgram et cetera continue
à être actif à propager des contenus y
compris y compris désinformation et
hostile à la présence française on l'a
bien vu au moment de la prise de Kidal
où Wagner a a essayé de de de se servir
de cet événement pour en fait
revaloriser aussi et relégitimer son
rôle dans la région après la mort de de
Prigogine et en même temps on voit aussi
une tentative de recyclage d'un certain
nombre d'anciens de Wagner par les
structures étatiques du ministère de la
Défense ou du du guou euh notamment dans
le cadre de cette organisation euh qui
s'appelle l'Africa corpse euh donc qui a
été euh euh qui a été mise en place à
l'initiative du ministère de la Défense
russe et notamment de son vice-ministre
euh youusbeck yevkurov qui est une
figure très importante de cette on
pourrait dire de cette deuxeme phase euh
de l'expansion de la présence russe euh
en Afrique subsaharienne euh et qui fait
des tournées euh dans toutes les dans en
Libye et puis dans dans les pays
sahéliens justement pour incarner cette
cette nouvelle cette nouvelle présence
russe et enfin et je termine là il faut
bien se rappeler toujours que une
stratégie d'influence n'est efficace que
lorsqu'elle s'appuie aussi sur un
écosystème beaucoup plus large que les
acteurs nationaux qu' en sont qui qui en
sont à l'origine c'est ce que yosai
Benkler appelle dans ses travaux la la
propagande en
réseau et et ça les Russes l'ont
vraiment bien compris notamment en
Afrique c'est-à-dire
que il faut bien comprendre que ces
acteurs Russ ont cherché vraiment à
pénétrer des espaces informationnels et
médiatiques locaux à tisser des liens
avec des acteurs locaux de chacun de ces
pays qui vont agir pour des raisons
lucratives militantes idéologiques
parfois les trois ensemble qui vont agir
au service de la présence russe mais qui
ont aussi parfois leur propre agenda
c'est-à-dire que je j'attire votre
attention sur le fait qu'il faut pas
penser cette vision qui serait en fait
très néocoloniale comme quelque chose
d'extrêmement vertical euh finalement
ces acteurs ont aussi des intérêts ou
trouvent un intérêt à coopérer avec avec
des acteurs russes euh RT sputnic ont
par exemple signé 23 accords de
coopération avec des médias africains
qui sont soit des médias généralistes ou
des agences de presse soit des médias
alternatifs ou contrehégémoniques qui
est vraiment la ligne aussi de de de RT
et spoutnque et donc qui participe en
fait aussi à la la diffusion de leur
contenu dans dans les pays africain vous
avez aussi une forme d'externalisation
d'influence qu'on voit bien avec une une
une tent de s'appuyer sur des leaders
d'opinion et des activistes locaux pour
justement servir aussi de parfois de on
pourrait dire de blanchisseur si vous
voulez des récits russes je pense
évidemment à la figure la plus connue
qui est Kemy Seba dont on sait qu'il a
été financé à hauteur de 400000 dollars
par Wagner qui était à Moscou d'ailleurs
ces derniers jours notamment au m guimau
vous avez d'autres entrepreneurs de des
informformation qu'on les appelle aussi
comme arunaadamba et puis enfin et je
m'arrête là vous avez des des médias qui
sont financés par les acteurs russes et
notamment par par Wagner je pense à
radio lingosongo ou le S Johnny Sango en
république centra-fricaine qui sont
toujours actifs aujourd'hui on savait
qu'ils étaient financés par une une
entreprise de de prospection minière
liée à Wagner en RCA aujourd'hui c'est
très compliqué de savoir s'il y a eu un
de nouveaux circuits de financement mais
en tout cas tout ça pour dire que malgré
malgré cette la mort de Prigogine on
voit que Wagner est toujours présent que
son héritage est conservé en réalité par
l'étarus qui comprend bien que il ne
peut pas remplacer tout cet écosystème
du jour au lendemain et qu'il a intérêt
à s'appuyer sur sur ces activs là pour
pour continuer à péréniser cette
influence voilà je m'arrête là je si
vous voulez on on peut rentrer dans le
détail mais merci pour votre attention
merci pour cette intervention je trouve
ce qui est particulièrement étonnant
c'est cette capacité à la fois à
développer un discours anticolonialiste
alors que en même temps la Russie comp
comportement de prédation en Afrique et
va même envahir son voisin et donc je
pense que cette question du champ
informationnel elle est absolument
capital pour voir comment il peut être
utilisé je dire à l'inverse des des
comportements des des uns et des autres
dans le cadre d'une d'une stratégie bien
établie alors après cette ce premier
propos sur la Russie je propose de
passer la parole à Paul Charon pour nous
parler de la la Chine merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs les les
députés je voudrais commencer
par dire que ma présentation portera
essentiellement sur la stratégie
informationnelle de de de la Chine
également
euh stratégie informationnel qui
maintenant est assez bien connu dans ses
dimensions disons mondial et puis
surtout pour les terrains asiatique
européen et nord-américain mais beaucoup
moins pour le terrain africain d'où
l'intérêt de de de se pencher sur sur
cette question il faut commencer par
rappeler que cette stratégie
informationnelle ou stratégie narrative
discursive de la Chine en Afrique
s'inscrit d'abord dans une stratégie
plus globale euh qu'on peut résumer en
en en trois point euh d'abord l'enjeu
c'est de maintenir l'hégémonie du parti
sur le système politique chinois ça ça
passe par la lutte contre les cinq
poisons bien évidemment hein
donc les tawanais les Ouigours les
Tibétains les dissidents démocrates et
les falongons euh et puis ça passe aussi
par la production d'une image positive
de la Chine hein ce qui était au cœur
des stratégies informationnelles
chinoises pendant pendant
longtemps le deuxème point c'est la
défense de la souveraineté chinoise et
notamment de sa souveraineté
territoriale d'où la
lutte très rude menée par la Chine pour
éliminer tout soutien diplomatique à
Taïwan en Afrique et enfin ça passe
par l'ambition de façonner un
environnement favorable à la Chine donc
l'ambition de peser sur les normes les
institutions les standards techniques
mais aussi les
idées sur le terrain africain plus
particulièrement l'objectif de la Chine
c'est d'abord de développer une
stratégie informationnelle qui
favorise la construction l'établissement
le renforcement des relations
sinino-africaines en montrant notamment
tout le bénéfice que ces pays peuvent
peuvent trouver à établir des relations
avec Pékin et deuxièm
affaiblir les
États-Unis et de manière plus large le
modèle démocratique donc là ça passe par
la production cette fois-ci d'une image
négative de l'adversaire et du modèle
démocratique d'une manière générale en
montrant notamment tous les effets
néfastes de l'interventionnisme
américain et plus largement occidental
alors c'est les enjeux informationnels
sont ont été identifié depuis longtemps
par par la
Chine dès l'arrivée au pouvoir de
stining l'année suivante en 2013 il y a
eu une conférence très importante sur la
la propagande et le travail idéologique
qui a identifié le champ informationnel
comme un champ de bataille euh et qui a
placé les euh acteurs du champ
informationnel chinois au centre de de
de cette stratégie euh ce qui est assez
caractéristique aussi c'est le sentiment
des Chinois d'être encerclé sur le plan
informationnel et donc d'avoir à lutter
contre des eur qui pour l'instant
occupent très largement le terrain et
sont bien plus
efficaces que les médias les médias
chinois d'où la volonté dès 2014 de
ctinping de construire des médias de
rang international les modèles sont CNN
aljazira pour rivaliser avec l'Occident
et imposer les récits chinois alors le
dispositif à l'innational il est il est
bien connu aujourd'hui il y a quatre
grands médias qui mènent cette lutte à
information Nationel chinroa donc
l'agence de presse radio Chine
Internationale cgtn qui est la la le
versant internationale de la télé
chinoise CCTV et le China Deli ils
produisent deux types de de publication
des publications publiqu donc des
articles des des émissions des
reportages qui visent un certain nombre
d'audiences et des publications internes
à destination du parti donc il servent
aussi de dispositif d'information pour
le pouvoir chinois euh les on peut
facilement identifier les les les les
récits et les motifs
argumentatif récurrent dans dans cette
stratégie informationnelle avec de
manière très
intéressante uneulté globalement de la
Chine à parler des problèmes locaux la
stratégie informationnelle de la Chine
en Afrique reste très centrée sur la
Chine elle-même donc on produit une
image positive de la Chine et on parle
de l'action des acteurs chinois en
Afrique mais beaucoup de difficultés à
se saisir des problématiques locales euh
comme le font les les russe par par
exemple donc les les récits les plus
forts les plus qui dominent la stratégie
chinoise c'est d'abord l'idée de
construire une communauté de destin
Chine-Afrique qui elle-même s'inscrit
dans une communauté de destin pour
l'humanité c'est la dénonciation de
l'hégémonie
américaine c'est la présentation de la
démocratie américaine comme malade
vicier dysfonctionnel en interne
béliqueuse à
l'extérieur désireuse de propager des
révolutions de couleur
partout c'est l'idée encore de
promouvoir un monde multipolaire et de
réformer la gouvernance mondiale et
c'est
enfin une tendance à mettre en avant les
changements positifs en Afrique mais en
essayant de les lier le plus souvent
possible à des actions de la Chine la
Chine serait responsable en quelque
sorte des des changements positifs qui
se produisent en Afrique alors la
stratégie informationnelle chinoise on
peut la la la découp en quatre grandes
catégories d'action d'abord une action
de propagande qui repose bah sur
l'accroissement de la présence
médiatique de la Chine en
Afrique qui passe par plus de moyens
plus de bureaux implantés dans de plus
en plus de pays euh des productions dans
de plus en plus de langues avec un
effort notamment sur le laousa et le le
le kisoilii euh une diffusion de contenu
dans les médias locaux traditionnels
euh et en ligne bien bien
évidemment ça passe ensuite par la
censure qui prend différentes forme
l'intimidation de journalistes locaux ou
occidentaux des attaques cyber
des campagnes de trolling donc pour
intimider là aussi et la prise de
contrôle d'un certain nombre
d'infrastructure de communication locale
ça passe ensuite par les manipulations
de
l'information là c'est des méthodes
assez connu encore he méthode
d'amplification notamment de de de
campagnes informationnell chinoise la
production de faux contenus
d'information manipulée l'utilisation de
faux comptes sur les réseaux sociaux la
mise en œuvre de campagnes coordonnées
on a pu identifier plusieurs et une
tendance plus récente mais de plus en
plus forte de simulation de
l'authenticité notamment en recrutant
des relais locaux qui s'expriment dans
les médias chinois euh ou via des
comptes qui sont anonymisés ou dont on
efface les liens avec avec les les
agences chinoises ça passe ensuite par
enfin par l'exportation du modèle
chinois euh via la formation des
journalistes euh avec parfois certains
dans certains pays près de 80 % des
journalistes qui ont été formés par la
Chine et un soutien technique aux médias
locaux alors pour illustrer ça très
rapidement je voudrais détailler un tout
petit peu le cas du
Sénégal qui est le cas le plus le plus
intéressant en Afrique
francophone pas le plus grave en Afrique
le le cas là où la pénétration chinoise
est la plus forte c'est
vraisemblablement au Nigéria au Kenya en
Afrique du Sud mais en Afrique
francophone c'est c'est au Sénégal là on
a un champ informationnel assez
intéressant avec finalement des contenus
produits par la Chine ou diffusés par la
Chine qui mettent en avant les
réalisations de la Chine en Afrique ou
en Chine par exemple sa capacité à
gérer la pandémie de de de covid-19 qui
est mise en regard du
chaos des hôpitaux européens ou
nord-américains avec l'idée bien sûr
qu'un régime autoritaire comme celui de
la Chine gère beaucoup mieux ce type de
crise qu'une démocratie l'idée étant de
démonétiser la démocratie elle-même les
avantag age économique pour le Sénégal
d'une coopération avec la Chine la
présentation de la Chine comme une ami
de l'Afrique et puis bien sûr une lutte
contre les prétendues violations des
droits de l'homme en Chine notamment au
sang ça passe bien sûr par une présence
médiatique locale chinoise
importante avec Radio Chine
Internationale mais aussi cgtn et
chineri qui dépose de qui dispose de
correspondants et de bureau locaux euh
une présence aussi de de de la
société de de diffusion via satellite de
de d'émission de télévision
startimes radio Chine Internationale
dispose de journalistes à la fois
chinois et locaux euh journalistes
sénégalais mais dont les productions
sont contrôlées toujours par Pékin euh
une part importante d'ailleurs de la
production informationnelle médiatique
euh est directement issue de de médias
chinois euh et couvre bien entendu
d'abord les activités de la Chine sur le
sol africain cette stratégie repose
aussi sur des accords d'échange de
contenu euh C web par exemple donc qui
est un l'un des principaux sites
d'information
euh au Sénégal mais dans l'ensemble de
de l'Afrique francophone euh a établi un
accord de de d'échange de contenu avec
chinroa en 2017 et bien que le le le
responsable de C web se
se a expliqué à plusieurs reprises qu'il
continuait de produire enfin de se
nourrir via d'autres agences de presse
et qu'il était prudent vis-à-vis de
l'information venue de Chine quand on
regarde un peu plus près on se rend
compte que c'est pas tout à fait le cas
et que nombre d'informations est
directement issue des médias chinois
sans dimension critique de la part des
des journalistes de cweb euh cweb a
également diffusé de nombreux discours
ou articles de l'ambassade de Chine au
Sénégal mettant l'accent sur la
coopération cino-africaine sur les
réalisations du FOCAC par exemple h
d'autres accords existent également avec
le quotidien Le Soleil et aussi avec
l'agence de presse sénégalaise la
PS là aussi avec de nombreuses articles
directement repris par ces médias euh
donc des articles de médias chinois
directement repris par les médias
sénégalais sans dimension critique euh
présence également alors plus réduite
sur les réseaux sociaux euh au Sénégal
c'est les médias chinois disposent de
comptes sur sur Twitter euh sur Facebook
mais qui sont assez peu actif pour le
moment
euh les les journalistes Sénégalais ont
bénéficié de nombreux voyages euh et
programme de formation en Chine euh pour
la seule année
2019 c'est une trentaine de rédacteurs
en chef cadre et médias euh de
médias cadre de médias et journalistes
de de de de médias sénégalais qui ont pu
se rendre en Chine le programme a
ensuite été rompu a été interrompu en
raison de la la pandémie de covid-19
mais reprend reprend tout doucement eu
il y a une présence aussi de de
d'acteurs chinois dans le domaine des
infrastructures de communication
startimes je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
mais aussi Huawei
euh de transion donc qui est un acteur
qui produit des des des téléphones à
Bakou le Sénégal est aussi très
intéressé par le modèle de gouvernance
de souveraineté des données chinois et
entend s'en inspirer dans le contrôle de
l'information la diaspora en revanche et
je m'arrêterai là joue un rôle
relativement limité au Sénégal on a on a
identifié deux comptes wichat qui jouent
un rôle important en direction de cette
population c'est le compte de Chin roi
Africa et le compte
de chineafrique donc qui est issu de de
l'ambassade de Chine voilà pour une
présentation un petit peu plus détaillée
du Sénégal et qui montre bien l'étendue
de la pénétration chinoise sur le plan
informationnel merci merci Paul chon
donc après la présentation sur la Russie
sur la Chine on termine par la Turquie
avec Jonathan
guffard merci monsieur le président
ident mesdames messieurs les députés je
vais donc vous parler de la stratégie
turque en Afrique je vais vous faire ça
rapidement passant d'abord par un un
petit prise de recul historique et en
vous parla ensuite des motivations et
des outils de de cette
stratégie prise de recul historique
pourquoi parce que il faut avoir
conscience que l'Afrique n'est
absolument pas un sujet pour les Turcs
après la chute de l'Empire ottoman et ce
jusqu'à la fin du 20e siècle c'est que
ce n'est que en 1998 qu' un premier plan
de coopération Turquie Affrique apparaît
et c'est important de le noter il
apparaît donc l'année d'après le premier
rejet de la candidature
européenne de la Turquie c'est important
parce que ça fait lien avec le fait que
des penseurs et notamment un ancien
Premier ministre turc Ahmed davutolou a
écrit un livre sur la nécessité pour la
Turquie de s'affirmer comme une
puissance moyenne ce livre il date de
2001 et en passant notamment par une
repr
de cette politique dans la profondeur
stratégique turque et notamment ottomane
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on parle de
néotomanisme même si c'est un terme qui
est un peu galvodé mais mais ça part de
ce point de départ là qui est de se dire
que la l'Afrique est un endroit une
région à investir pour la Turquie et
qu'il faut y mettre des moyens cette
stratégie du coup c'est mon deuxième
point effectivement une stratégie certes
qui n'est pas ancienne à l'échelle du
20e siècle mais qui finalement a 25 ans
on en parle beaucoup aujourd'hui mais
elle a 25 ans elle est cohérente et elle
est elle s'inscrit vraiment dans la
durée de la prise de pouvoir de laakp du
parti de REEP tayp Erdogan et de cette
volonté d'affirmer la puissance turque à
l'international donc elle est fortement
pensée par Ahmed davutolou dont je vous
ai parlé et elle est mise en œuvre par
laakp et par le gouvernement d'erdoan
dans la durée il y a une accélération
qui a lieu à partir de 2016 2016 c'est
la date juillet 2016 c'est la date du
coup d'état manqué contre rejep Tayip
Erdogan par le mouvement guléniste il y
a une accélération pourquoi parce que le
mouvement guléniste qui était jusque-l
allié de la Capp a beaucoup investi
l'Afrique notamment avec des écoles
notamment avec des programmes
humanitaire avec de la coopération et à
partir de ce moment-là on voit la
Turquie
reprendre une politique encore plus
affirmé vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
africains notamment pour déguléniser
toute la présence turque en Afrique les
motivations de la politique turque euh
il y en a plusieurs donc la première je
viens de vous en parler c'est cette
lutte antiguléniste qui est assez
structurante depuis 2016 qui se tasse un
peu maintenant parce que quelque part le
le le régime turc a réussi sa
dégulinisation et beaucoup de
partenaires africains ont fermé les
écoles gulénistes euh ù ont arrêté de
soutenir ou de recevoir de l'aide de ce
mouvement euh c'est vrai à l'ensemble à
l'échelle de la planète mais c'est
particulièrement vrai en Afrique
cette donc deuxième motivation cette
volonté de s'affirmer comme une
puissance moyenne et ça vous voyez bien
avec la Russie avec la Chine et avec
d'autres pays l'Afrique est une un grand
continent il y a 54 pays et c'est
extrêmement intéressant quand vous vous
affirmez d'aller développer des
partenariats avec tous ces pays à
l'image de la Chine et de la Russie la
Turquie a tout à fait identifié la
vulnérabilité des Occidentaux et
particulièrement des Français sur le
continent africain c'est un levier assez
facile à utiliser en revanche la
différence de la Chine et de la Russie
et ça c'est une spécificité de la
Turquie elle a aussi très bien identifié
son lien culturel et religieux avec un
ensemble de pays et de population
musulmane en Afrique et elle en joue
beaucoup de cette proximité religieuse
et culturelle lev que ne peuvent pas
utiliser d'autres puissances comme la
Chine et la
Russie c'est aussi une politique est
structurée par une compétition notamment
qui a eu lieu qui s'est un peu calmé
aujourd'hui mais qui a eu lieu pendant
longtemps avec les ém arabe uni surfond
euh d'une tension entre deux courants de
l'islam politique mais c'est important
parce que sur le territoire africain
enfin du coup sur le continent africain
cette compétition a eu un impact assez
important dans la motivation des Turcs à
rallier des partenaires ou à ou à ou à
s'engager dans des crises et je j'y
reviendrai euh enfin un dernier point
quand même parce qu'on le dit pas assez
souvent euh la politique étrangère
turque c'est effectivement un moyen de
s'affirmer comme une puissance moyenne
mais ça reste avant tout un moyen de
légitimer le pouvoir à l'intérieur de
ces frontières et ça c'est quand même
très très important parce que la
population turque et notamment la
population qui soutient le gouvernement
de REP tayep Erdogan est tout à fait
heureuse que la Chine s'affirme à
l'international dans les faits il y a
une un intérêt tout à fait relatif pour
ces crises internationales et il y a
même une partie de la population qui
considère que ces crises sont auss un
fardeau pour la Turquie donc c'est il
faut quand même garder en tête que c'est
un une logique de légitimation à
l'intérieur de ces frontières d'abord et
avant tout euh
donc la Turquie pour cette stratégie met
en place beaucoup d'outils beaucoup
d'outils différents et et et et propose
une stratégie qui est extrêmement vaste
et exhaustive et je pense que c'est
important de le souligner parce que si
vous voulez faire de l'influence sur
n'importe quel continent ou à
l'international il faut mobiliser
l'ensemble des outils que vous avez et
la Turquie le montre relativement bien
tout d'abord sa présence diplomatique
qui effectivement au tout début a
démarré par 12 ambassades et aujourd'hui
il y en a
44 c'est sa présence diplomatique a
augmenté c'est très important et a
permis d'avoir une présence sur le
terrain très forte je vous parlais de la
lutte antigulénis il y a une fondation
qui s'appelle la Fondation Marif
aujourd'hui qui est utilisé pour
justement proposer des programmes
scolaires et proposer un certain nombre
de Coopé tion elle a eu pour mission de
l'État turc de reprendre la main sur les
écoles les écoles gulénistes et
effectivement elle est très active sur
le continent vous avez l'Agence de
développement la TICA qui est aussi très
importante qui a ouvert 22 bureaux sur
le continent et qui s'engage fortement
dans le domaine du développement
bilatéral multilatéral aussi mais
surtout bilatéral avec les différents
partenaires africains vous avez et c'est
pas les un des moindres outils de
l'influence turque la turky Charline qui
a a ouvert un nombre de lignes aériennes
tout à
fait enfin tout à fait importante et je
suis sûr que vous avez tous dû voir que
il est aujourd'hui moins cher d'aller en
Afrique de l'Ouest en passant par la
Turkish shirline que par Air France et
ça c'est quelque chose de très
significatif parce que ça fait un effet
réseau qui est très important c'estàd
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de de
d'Africains notamment en Afrique de
l'Ouest qui voyagent en Turquie ou qui
voyage en Europe via la Turquie eu vous
avez une coopération économique qui est
assez importante ENF c'est un outil qui
est qui est quand même très important
qui a accès sur des secteurs très
spécifiques comme le BTP comme la
construction d'infrastructure un petit
peu le minier euh comme les la vente
aussi de produits manufacturés et j'y
reviendrai mais il y a un point
important à comprendre aussi c'est que
depuis 2018 et la crise économique
turque enfin la crise économique que
vous voyez en Turquie en est à la fois
le symptôme et le moteur mais depuis
2018 la Turquie euh transforme son
économie pour faire une une économie
d'exportation très importante et
l'Afrique représente un terrain euh
gigantesque pour exporter des produits
Turcs vous avez aussi la coopération
universitaire qui est très importante il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de de de
d'étudiants africains qui viennent à
différents niveaux que ça soit
équivalent licence master en tout cas
qui viennent récupérer beaucoup de
diplômes qui viennent s'in enfin qui
viennent s'éduquer en Turquie mais aussi
euh en République chipriote du Nord euh
ce qui ce qui est pas anodin parce que
il y a beaucoup de coopération et donc
il a beaucoup beaucoup d'étudiants
étrangers qui viennent étudier vous avez
aussi une coopération culturelle qui
passe par les institut youunous EMR vous
avez une coopération dans le milieu des
syndicats notamment des syndicats
patronaux mais aussi des syndicats de
travailleurs qui font toute une
diplomatie économique horizontale dans
beaucoup de pays
africains et enfin vous avez enfin enfin
vous avez bien entendu beaucoup d'ONG
notamment d'ONG musulmanes qui viennent
apporter une aide humanitaire une aide
dans le domaine du développement une
aide dans le domaine de l'éducation et
ça ça se fait beaucoup vous voyez aussi
une offensive médiatique et bien entendu
une coopération militaire coopération
militaire qui est axé à la fois sur un
engagement militaire là il y a deux pays
qui sont très importants la Libye et la
Somalie où il y a une présence turque
permanente et vous avez bien entendu ça
a été évoqué par Monsieur le Président
une coopération orientée autour de la
vente de matériel et d'armement et dont
le le drone TB2 en est l'emblème
aujourd'hui il y a pas moins de 7 pays
en AF Afrique de l'Ouest qui en ont ou
qui en ont commandé trois en Afrique de
l'Est et ça ne va faire que continuer il
faut il faut en être sûr et enfin une
coopération sécuritaire avec notamment
des le un rôle particulier donné au
service de renseignement turc ou à des
SMP comme la SMP Sadat pour aller
extrêmement vite les axes de progression
je vous ai parlé de la Libye je vous ai
parlé de la Somalie ça c'est les deux
têtes de pont de l'influence turque
parce qu'il y a une présence militaire
permanente parce que c'est orienté
autour d'un soutien politique à des
acteurs gouvernementaux et notamment de
la formation militaire
eu cette présence est importante
néanmoins elle se développe aussi par
exemple au Maghreb où il y a un effort
significatif des Turcs pour engager sur
le plan économique et sur le plan
politique les différents pays du Maghreb
vous avez aussi une présence qui
s'affirme au Sahel mais qui reste
limitée mais qui s'affirme quand même
notamment par le biais de la cette
diplomatie de défense en tout cas par le
biais de vendre d'équipements militaires
euh sur le plan politique c'est un peu
différent euh donc pour terminer
quelques idées à retenir mon AM qui me
semblent importantes la stratégie turque
a donc 25 ans elle est discrète mais
elle est ambitieuse et elle sera
continue elle ne s'arrêtera pas elle
sert d'affirmation de la puissance
turque par du hard power même si elle
utilise aussi beaucoup beaucoup d'outils
de soft power notamment les et enfin
d'une part beaucoup d'outils de soft
power et d'autre part la la coopération
économique qui est vraiment un point
important de cette stratégie elle
mobilise on en a parlé aussi des
narratifs anticoloniaux et des narratifs
anti-occidentaux pourquoi parce que
c'est facile il y a pas de faut pas
aller chercher beaucoup plus loin c'est
facile à utiliser d'une part et d'autres
elle utilise elle mobilise sa proximité
religieuse et culturelle avec un certain
nombre de partenaires musulmans dans la
région enfin son positionnement central
et important et ça j'insiste parce que
ça permet de faire des effets d'échelle
et des effets de réseau le fait de de
centraliser autour d'elle d'attirer des
des des partenaires africains des
étudiants africains des entreprises de
proposer des facilités
infrastructurelles à commencé par la
Turquie shline c'est important parce
qu'elle se place au milieu de ce
continent et on est obligé de passer par
la Turquie pour quelque part en terme
politique en terme économique pour
rejoindre le
continent en revanche il y a deux points
qui me semblent importants il y a une
limite très forte c'est la limite de
autanienne ce que j'appelle la limite
autanienne c'est que vous verrez pas la
Turquie avoir une politique agress comme
la Russie et la Chine parce qu'une
partie de sa politique est légitimée par
sa présence dans l'OTAN sa présence en
Libye par exemple est légitimé par sa
présence dans l'OTAN les Américains la
soutiennent et c'est important de
l'avoir en tête parce que les Turcs
pourront passer quelques lignes rouge
notamment vis-à-vis de partenaires avec
lesquels il peut y avoir des tensions
comme la France mais de manière générale
elle passera pas à l'agression directe
et une deuxième limite qui est aussi un
paradoxe c'est qu'on parle aujourd'hui
c'est le but de la stratégie turque en
Afrique c'est une stratégie turque très
importante néanmoins elle en terme de
valeur en terme de budget en terme
d'engagement et même en terme de quelque
part de priorité politique elle est
beaucoup moins importante que la
stratégie turque en Asie centrale ou que
la stratégie turque dans les Balcans il
faut savoir que l'aide au développement
turque en Afrique est inférieure à
l'aide au développement turc dans les
Balcans à partir de là ça vous remet un
peu près les les perspectives je vous
remercie merci à tous les trois pour ces
présentations vraiment
éclairante sur trois acteurs qui je
pense se coordonnent assez peu mais qui
finalement on voit bien ont un agenda à
commun à la fois de de de puissance et
également un agenda vous l'avez un peu
évoqué de réaffirmissement du d'un
consensus interne finalement il y a
aussi des questions politiques internes
qui drivent beaucoup leur agendat de
puissance à l'extérieur quel que soit
même j'allais dire la nature du du
régime et ce que je retiens c'est que si
finalement il y a un agenda assez commun
il y a des modalités d'intervention qui
peuvent être un peu un peu varié avec
euh côté russe plutôt une dominante
sécuritaire et qui s'appuie sur le
narratif anti-français côté chinois un
angle économique et qui s'appuie dans un
agenda également de puissance globale
très tourné vers les vers les États-Unis
d'Amérique et puis côté turc vous l'avez
très bien dit cette volonté de
s'affirmer comme une puissance moyenne
en appuyant beaucoup également sur des
leviers de coopération culturels et et
éducatif et d'ailleurs on a une mission
d'information en cours
à ce sujet-là pour réfléchir aussi à
quel point ces leviers culturels
éducatif peuvent être utilisé à la fois
pour réaffermir le le consensus national
mais également pour être utilisé en tant
que soft power dans tous les cas j'ai
bien noté que quels que soient les les
compétiteurs tous avait un une stratégie
informationnelle extrêmement forte d'une
certaine manière pour pour imposer un
peu leur leur narratif et tous avait
également un pilier sécuritaire
extrêmement fort pas d'influence sans
sans puissance je pense c'est c'est la
base en tout cas nous notre
responsabilité c'est de contribuer à ce
que pourrait être la la stratégie
française et européenne dans ce contexte
là alors nous allons prendre désormais
les interventions des orateurs de groupe
pour le groupe Renaissance la parole est
à Patricia Lemoine et alors pour rendre
les choses plus dynamiques aussi je vous
propose si vous voulez de d'apporter des
réponses après chaque orateur de groupe
donc si possible si l'orateur de groupe
peut cibler une des trois personnes pour
sa question ça peut être bien pour être
le plus efficace possible très bien
merci monsieur le Président je tiens
tout d'abord à remercier au nom du
groupe Renaissance nos trois
intervenants pour leur expertise tout à
fait enrichissante vous l'avez évoqué
les stratégies d'influence de pays tels
que la Russie la Chine ou la Turquie
prennent de multiples formes elles se
déploie aussi bien sur le plan
diplomatique que militaire tant dans la
coopération humanitaire que commerciale
sans oublier bien sûr l'organisation de
grands sommets comme celui de
Saint-Pétersbourg cette année
euh
ou le sommet
russiearique pour le sommet Russie
Afrique pardon celui d'istanbou en 2021
pour le sommet turquie-afrique ces
influences concurrentes s'avèrent
problématiques pour la stabilité du
continent africain d'autant que
contrairement à la France ces
compétiteurs proposent de répondre aux
besoins immédiats des pays africains
sans jamais conditionner leur aide à des
exigences de gouvernance ou de droits
humains par ailleurs et vous l'avez dit
ces pays mènent une véritable guerre
informationnelle contre la France en
exacerbant le sentiment anti-rançais
dans les opinions publiques
africaines je ne citerai que l'exemple
bien connu de la milice Wagner qui
organise des campagnes de désinformation
contre l'armée française et vous l'avez
dit la disparition d'evgéie Prigogine le
23 août dernier emporte des conséquences
importantes sur la structuration de
Wagner en Afrique dont nous ne mesurons
pas pour le moment les effets à moyen et
long terme la France est bien sûr lucide
quant à sa perte d'influence sur le
continent et nous voyons bien le risque
de nos compétiteurs de nous imposer un
narratif pessimiste selon la lequel la
France n'aurait plus aucun rôle à jouer
en Afrique ces nouvelles puissances sont
pourtant porteuses de contradictions
qu'il convient de mettre en exerg je
pense notamment à la relation
asymétrique que construit la Chine avec
les pays euh dont elle est la principale
créancière et qui tente à fragiliser ces
derniers plutôt qu'à encourager leur
développement ma question est donc
simple selon vous de quel levier
disposons-nous pour inverser la tendance
et réaffirmer auprès de ces pays que la
présence française concourt à la
stabilité du continent je vous remercie
et donc ma question s'adresse plutôt à
Paul Charon très bien char vous avez la
parole
euh merci Madame la député la question
est simple la réponse ne l'est pas euh
euh et je suis plutôt un spécialiste de
la Chine et j'aurais du mal à à à
formuler une réponse pertinente je pense
euh sur les réponses que la France
pourra apporter en tout cas il y a une
chose qui m'a interpellé dans ce que
vous avez dit et et qui montre euh la
capacité de la Chine à imposer un
certain nombre de récits y compris dans
dans nos institutions euh vous avez
expliqué que euh les Chinois comme les
Russes ou ou les Turcs peut-être euh
n'impose pas de enfin ne pratique pas
l'ingérence dans les modèle politique
étranger ne ne demande aucune
contrepartie politique c'est faux
euh la Chine impose à tous les États
d'Afrique qu'il ne reconnaissent pas
Taïwan si ça ce n'est pas une ingérence
dans la diplomatie de ces pays je ne
sais pas ce que c'est et ça c'est par
exemple une arme qu'on devrait utiliser
plus souvent dire mais attendez nous on
a quelques exigences démocratiques et
cetera mais les chinois ils ont eux
aussi des exigences euh les médias
locaux ne peuvent pas parler de tous les
sujets qu'ils souhaitent ils peuvent pas
parler de ils peuvent pas parler de ce
qui se passe en Chine si ça indispose le
Parti communiste chinois ils peuvent pas
parler de Taiwan ils peuvent pas parler
du shinang des des Ouigours des
Tibétains et cetera et voilà d'une
manière générale
euh je crois qu'il faut euh
ne pas céder à la tentation de de
d'imiter les Russes et les Chinois dans
leur modèle très agressif utilisant la
désinformation et cetera je pense qu'il
faut se déprendre de cette de cette
tentation et au contraire
essayer de promouvoir des
interprétations des récits qui nous
avantage et qui dévoile la réalité de
l'action de la Chine mais ça c'est un
a du quotidien j'ai envie de dire et qui
ne pourra être achevé que que voilà par
petite touche voilà c'est un travail
impressionniste maximein et Jonathan
guffard je sais pas si vous souhaitez
rajouter quelqu monsieur Giffard oui moi
je veux bien étant avant tout d'abord un
spécialiste de l'Afrique effectivement
j'ai quelques éléments j'ai déjà écrit
sur sur ce sujet par exemple c'est pour
ça par exemple que j'ai insisté sur le
la logique de réseau et de centralité
euh je pense que la France est en train
de perdre cette centralité sur le
continent africain et pour être central
il faut être attractif et donc déjà il y
a un sujet d'attractivité euh un quelque
chose qui revient beaucoup euh c'est la
c'est l'attractivité dans le domaine
universitaire c'est-à-dire que nos
coopérations et le fait qu'on aide des
partenaires africains à former leurs
étudiants à former leur fonctionnair à
former un certain nombre de gens c'est
une politique qui diminue c'est une
politique qui a changé aussi avec la
politique de coopération et une forme
d'abandon de la politique de coopération
dans les années 90 euh quand je parlais
de turky Charline Air France c'est un
sujet parmi d'autres mais ça revient à
cette centralité si vous permettez en
fait aux gens en Afrique de venir
travailler s'éduquer s'informer faire de
la science faire de la coopération
économique rencontrer des entreprises en
fait ici euh ben quelque part vous
augmentez votre
attractivité et à ce titre là euh et je
finir là-dessus mais à ce titre là il
faut savoir que si cette attractivité
diminue
euh par rapport à ses concurrents et ces
concurrents dont on vient de parler mais
notamment aussi les concurrents
américains par exemple qui se rendent
très attractifs auprès des populations
des élites africaines il faut savoir
aussi que la l'histoire commune qu'on a
et notamment la langue qu'on partage
fait que l'ensemble de nos débats
politiques sont très très suivis en
Afrique de l'Ouest et ça ça a un impact
extrêmement fort sur
l'attractivité très bien Maximo pourra
répondre par la suite aussi à cette
question au travers d'une autre
intervention pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
José
merci monsieur le Président messieur les
chercheurs merci de votre présence et
merci d'avoir répondu à l'avance aux
questions que je vais vous poser
maintenant si l'Afrique semble
aujourd'hui pour partie rejeter le
modèle et la pensée occidentale elle
jette son dévolu sur des nations plus
dur parfois autoritaire qui s'avusaient
de leurs atouts pour s'implanter sur un
continent africain impacté d'ailleurs
par le terrorisme des nouveaux acteurs
sur le continent africain la Russie est
celui qui a le plus accru son influence
si son engagement ne date pas d'hier
Moscou s'appuie d'Oren avant sur des
moyens irréguliers souvent extraalégaux
pour étendre son influence mercenaire
des informations ingérance électorale
soutient au coup d'État et accord
d'chang d'armes contre des ressources la
Russie voulant ainsi s'assurer un
ancrage durable en Afrique et dans la
mer Rouge saper l'influence occidentale
et normaliser
l'autoritarisme la Chine est également
un acteur de premier plan en Afrique le
PCC cherche à diffuser une image positif
de la Chine et à contré ce que les
responsables chinois appellent la
diabolisation de la Chine par l'Occident
la Chine voit en l'Afrique un réservoir
de matières premières énergétiqu et
minièr et une possibilité d'étendre son
empire militaire et diplomatique elle
dispose ainsi d'une base navale
militaire stratégique à Djibouti et
pourrait vouloir en construire davantage
cependant sur le plan social politique
et environnementale la présence chinoise
en Afrique reste pose problème enfin la
Turquie fait également une grande peré
en Afrique ses relations commerciales
avec les pays africains sont en
augmentation sa stratégie va du soft
power au projet
d'infrastructure les entreprises de
bâtiment turc sont bien implantées et en
retour le continent africain devient un
fournisseur d'énergie et de matières
premières de plus en plus important avec
récep tayb Erdogan cette stratégie a
pris une dimension plus militaire enkara
y a installé sa plus grande base
militaire en dehors de ses frontières
par conséquent plusieurs questions
s'impose et il y en a pour tous les
goûts messieurs pour chacun d'entre vous
les relations russo-africaines
évolut-elles
évolueront-elles après la mort de
Prigogine en prenant directement en
charge les opérations de Wagner de
Wagner en Afrique le gouvernement russe
ne peut aujourd'hui plus prétendre à
l'ignorance ou à l'impuissance face aux
actions illégales et
déstabilisatrices en ce qui concerne la
Chine quels sont les apport au continent
africain est-elle un danger pour la
démocratie ou ou l'économie africaine au
niveau des relations avec la Turquie
quelles sont les contreparties pour le
continent africain pensez-vous que ces
différents acteurs arriveront à coopérer
en Afrique l'Occident a-t-il un rôle à
jouer doit-il se concentrer sur ses pays
alliés ou adopter des stratégies
similaires à celle de nos concurrents je
vous remercie maximeinet je vous propose
de répondre notamment sur la question de
de Wagner oui alors sur j'ai j'ai
commencé à amorcer quelques pistes de
réflexion sur ça sur l'évolution des
relations russo-afrique alors
effectivement voilà comme je le disais
on on voit que cette présence
nonofficielle est en train peu à peu de
se euh je dirais de se fragmenter de se
d'être fragilisé
euh ce qui va se traduire par plusieurs
choses d'une part et c'est important de
le souligner parce que c'est
potentiellement un levier qu'on peut
actionner pour répondre à à la question
précédente aussi c'est que cette
recomposition de la présence russe ça
n'est pas exemple de tension euh entre
les acteurs russes- mêmes euh on l'a
bien vu par exemple en République
centrafricaine avec le départ de enfin
plutôt l'éviction de Vitalie perfilev
qui était le le chef de la branche
militaire de Wagner dont on sait qu'il a
manifesté beaucoup de comment dire
de beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup de
d'agacement d'énervement je sais pas
comment le qualifier mais à la suite de
la mort de de Prigogine dont il était
voilà très fidèle euh il a été placé par
un certain Denise Pavlov je renvoie au à
l'enquête de du collectif Allin on
Wagner qui a bien montré que c'était
voilà un un agent du du SVR donc les
services de renseignement extérieur
russe euh et et tout ça crée des
tensions entre ces différents acteurs ce
qu'on voit aussi beaucoup au Mali par
exemple où Wagner est très présent
cherche à se mettre en avant et
parallèlement à à cette volonté qu'on
voit pour le coup au Burkina qui est
vraiment le je dirais qui va devenir le
laboratoire de cette cette expansion d'
une présence officielle et étatique de
la Russie on voit qu'il y a différents
modèles en fait de recomposition qui
vont mettre qui sont en place et qui
vont et et et qui vont pouvoir enfin qui
vont qui vont s'observer deuxième chose
c'est aussi il faut s'attendre justement
à une perte de souplesse de flexibilité
dans les la capacité d'action de ces
acteurs puisque précisément Wagner qui
n'est pas vraiment vous le savez une
société militaire privée ni un acteur
étatique c'est quelque chose entre les
deux ce qui qui rend d'ailleurs cette
organisation ass c'est unique euh était
justement utilisé et a été créé pour
agir euh de manière beaucoup plus
désinhibé des complexé que ne peuvent le
faire des acteurs bureaucratiques et
étatiques même l'armée russe dont on
sait qu'elle s'est affranchie de toute
une série de de principe d'éthique de la
guerre et cetera en Ukraine et ça c'est
quelque chose aussi auquel il faut
s'attendre ce qui montre et ce qui se
traduit d'ailleurs dans les hésitations
de l'État russe vis-à-vis de l'héritage
de Wagner c'est-à-dire que parfois on se
rend bien compte notamment dans l'espace
informationnel que c'est peut-être
beaucoup plus intelligent de s'appuyer
sur
l'écosystème d'acteurs d'influence
informationnelle mis en place depuis des
années dans la région plutôt que de tout
remplacer du jour au lendemain en
s'appuyant sur des des unités du Grou ou
du SVR qui elles ont un savoir-faire et
une pratique moins importante dans dans
cette région voilà ce qu'on peut dire
très bien merci pour la France soumise
la parole est à Aurélien saintoule merci
monsieur le Président merci messieur
pour V présent tion alors quelques
observations d'ordre général
effectivement les trois puissances que
vous avez évoqué sont caractérisé
désormais par leur degré de
désinhibition sur la scène
internationale le fait que en réalité
rien ne les retiennent et certainement
pas les principes du
droit en revanche il est vrai aussi que
aujourd'hui si elles ont la possibilité
de s'exprimer c'est que vous disiez
monsieur guffard c'est qu'en réalité on
a en grande partie laisser la place et
puis parce que et c'est une réponse à
notre président euh ils ont la la chance
pour ainsi dire de ne pas avoir eux
colonisé l'Afrique au 19e siècle et
d'avoir d'une certaine façon une
possibilité de s'exprimer différemment
par ailleurs leurs messages sont
beaucoup plus faciles à véhiculer dans
la mesure où ils bénéficie aussi de
notre double standard et de nos
hypocrisies puisque la décolonisation
très imparfaite nous offre nous place
aujourd'hui comme de des des
interlocuteurs pas toujours crédibles et
puis parce que notre propre nos propres
décisions dans le champ de la politique
interne manifeste aussi une forme
d'hypocrisie voire de renoncement la
semaine dernière dans cette même
assemblée dans cette même commission
nous déplorions tous en rythme le fait
que la France n'avait pas de politique
de coopération universitaire à la
hauteur et hier nous avons voté encore
une nous avons voté en tout cas certains
ont voté ici la restriction de l'accès
des étudiants étrangers en France donc
un affaiblissement considérable de la
politique univers universitaire de ce
pays et évidemment au détriment en
particulier des étudiants africains qui
seront évidemment les plus vulnérables
au aux mesures contenues dans la loi sur
l'immigration donc je vous pose une
première question sur cette loi
immigration est-ce que vous partagez
l'analyse que je viens de faire est-ce
que vous considérez qu'elle offre d'une
certaine façon un boulevard au narratif
rus chinois et éventuellement turc la
deuxème question porte sur les les
enjeux généraux de la compétition parce
que on présente des compétiteurs mais
ils sont en avec nous nous sommes en
compétition avec ces puissances pour
quoi faire pour quels enjeux et puis la
troisième question porte sur les autres
compétiteurs ceux qui sont aussi nos
partenaires et en particulier les
États-Unis d'Amérique qui ne sont pas
absents on parlait de des Turcs qui
avaient créé une stratégie africaine en
98 c'est en 2008 que les États-Unis ont
créé Africom voilà je crois que ça n
pas l'Afrique n'est pas un champ
homogène où les uns et les autres
viendraient s s'affronterait sans sans
contrepartie donc j'aimerais avoir aussi
un aperçu sur le la bataille globale qui
se mène sur le terrain alors merci chers
collègues alors nousons trois questions
je sais pas qui veut commencer Paul chon
c'est vous qui avez commencé
précédemment ou alors sinon on peut
commencer par Jonathan guffard si vous
souhaitez alors Monsieur le Député je ne
vais pas me prononcer sur la loi
immigration d'hier c'est pas mon rôle
ici en revanche pour votre constat je
partage la désinhibition je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous il y a un il a
c'est un sujet euh mais c'est un sujet
qui pour répondre aussi une partie de la
question précédente euh c'est pas parce
qu'effectivement eux sont dans une
désinhibition que nous on doit l'être
nous on a un modèle à défendre on a des
valeurs à défendre et ça me paraît
important et pour relier à la première
question pour défendre ce modèle en
revanche peut-être qu'effectivement il y
a des tempos un peu différent et que
défendre la démocratie ça doit peut-être
pas se passer dans chacun des contrats
de gouvernance de développement qu'on a
avec nos partenaires nos partenaires ils
ont besoin d'une aide souvent assez
rapide et en fait quand vous parlez aux
populations malienne dont la moitié des
familles se fait massacré par des
djihadistes d'un côté ou par l'armée de
l'autre très clairement la gouvernance
démocratique et les règles et les
valeurs libérales c'est un besoin une
envie mais c'est clairement pas le sujet
du court terme donc il y a peut-être un
sujet de tempo là-dessus euh sur le
sujet du fait qu'on ait laissé la place
je partage aussi tout à fait ce ce
sujetl c'est plus largement le sujet de
non pas de la politique africaine de la
France mais d'une de considérer est-ce
que enfin de considérer d'un point de
vue français la nécessité d'investir
dans tous les domaines dont on a parlé
notamment universitaire notamment
culturel notamment militaire bref
l'ensemble l'ensemble de ces domaines là
et aussi de considérer que l'Afrique
c'est pas un pays çaen est 54 et donc il
faut travailler avec tous les
partenaires avec beaucoup d'entre eux
que les enjeux sont pas les mêmes sur le
sujet de la colonisation euh là je mets
un bémol sur la Turquie parce que la
Turquie a colonisé le nord de l'Afrique
euh et pour autant on en parle pas on en
parle peu et de manière générale je suis
pas sûr que ça soit très malin de le
faire encore une fois je suis pas sûr
que il faut qu'on utilise les mêmes
armes que que ces indiv enfin que ces
puissances là mais dans les faits et je
rejoins aussi le sujet du double
standard h moi je parlerai pas
totalement de double standard parce
qu'en vérité ces pays-là eux-mêmes on
peut leur reprocher un sacré nombre de
double standard en revanche pour moi il
y a un sujet de vulnérabilité si vous
voulez être influente dans une région il
faut diminuer vos propres vulnérabilités
et j'en reviens au sujet universitaire
mais j' reviens à d'autres sujets au
sujet des visas au sujet enfin bref un
ensemble de de de sujets qui sont mal
vécus par les populations au jour le
jour et qui nous rendent du coup plus
faible et donc le sujet du double
standard c'est plutôt le sujet de telle
ou telle politique si vous la prenez
posez-vous la question de savoir si ça
va vous renforcer ou si ça va vous
mettre dans une position de difficulté
qui sera aisément exploité par nos amis
russes et nos amis chinois mais les
doubles standards en fait tout le monde
en fait et ça c'est aussi important de
le souligner me semble-t-il est-ce que
simplement vous pourriez par rapport à
la première question nous dire quel est
le volume d'étudiants africains qui
accueilli en Turquie par exemple comme
vous avez beaucoup mis en valeur le la
coopération éducative culturelle là je
vais pas pouvoir vous sortir les
chiffres mais je pourrais essayer de
vous les vous les de vous les envoyer si
vous
voulez mais c'est un levier qui est
beaucoup utilisé l'accueil de oui c'est
un levier qui est beaucoup utilisé euh
en fait c'est un lev qui est beaucoup
utilisé notamment qui est mobilisé par
la
Turquie qui va proposer à ses
partenaires un certain nombre de déjà de
quotas en fait de de diplôme et de du
coup de en fait qui va proposer des
formations qui va avoir un certain
nombre d'universités enfin à Istanbul
encar dans beaucoup de villes turques
vous avez quand même des universités de
d'assez bon niveau et vous en avez
beaucoup qui accueillent ces étudiants
mais eux-mêmes les finance c'està-dire
qu'il y a en fait vous financez ben la
bourse complète vous financez l'année
d'études ou le diplôme et cetera donc
vous prenez en compte l'ensemble du
sujet et ça c'est assez important de ce
point de vue là merci Paul
Charon je vaux pas être trop long je je
je reprends à mon compte les les
réponses de Jonathan guffard juste un
mot aussi sur la
colonisation la Chine non plus n'est pas
exemple de de de colonialisme elle a
colonisé le shinang elle a colonisé le
Tibet euh
donc c'est c'est
pas un argument qu'il faut euh qu'il
faut euh leur laisser euh nécessairement
euh ça veut pas dire qu'il faut mettre
ça sous le tapis et pas pas en parler
mais mais mais qu'en tout cas on n' pas
à se sentir
euh plus handicapé euh que que que les
Chinois pour face à face à ce sujet euh
et euh comme comme ça a été dit juste
avant ils ont eux aussi comme les Turcs
et les Russes beaucoup de choses euh euh
à se reprocher beaucoup de beaucoup de
problèmes à gérer sur ce plan euh et
encore une fois comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il faut
imiter les méthodes russes ou ou
chinoise euh parce que ça reviendrait à
jouer leur jeux et à affaiblir en fin de
compte nos propres institutions et
l'idée l'idée de démocratie elle-même
merci merci et enfin donc maxiin qui
nous parlera peut-être des autres
compétiteurs que que l'on a cité alors
pour répondre à votre question euh oui
d'abord dire que euh il y a bien sûr une
une asymétrie dans la production de réis
s'agissant de l'Afrique puisque
effectivement la Russie n'a pas été une
puissance coloniale en Afrique et c'est
d'ailleurs un des grands problèmes côté
français dans ce qu'on dans cette
volonté de de de créer une nouvelle
stratégie nationale d'influence qui
passe par la création de récit et il y a
effectivement un
enjeu de contradiction ou un enjeu
extrêmement complexe vis-à-vis de notre
production de récit vis-à-vis de
l'Afrique sur ce sujet en en particulier
euh et et il y a aussi et ça je rejoins
ce qui vient d'être dit cet immense
paradoxe voir cette immense
contradiction dans le cas de de la
Russie qui est effectivement vous savez
on parle beaucoup en ce moment au sein
des études slaves euh de la nécessité de
décoloniser le champ des études slaves
mais il se trouve que justement
l'invasion de l'Ukraine a bien des
écarts est une est une guerre de type
néoimpériale voire néocoloniale euh et
tout ça advient dans le même temps sauf
qu'on a on a le sentiment au sein des
opinions africaines on le voit bien dans
un certain nombre de sondages réalisés
par exemple au Mali euh au Niger euh que
en fait cette cette cette vision là
n'imprime pas au sein des sociétés euh
de de ces société là en particulier qui
où où le la guerre en Ukraine est perçue
vraiment comme un un conflit euh entre
entre la Russie et l'Occident plus
largement avec une guerre par proxy qui
est évidemment un discours très très mis
en avant par par la propagande russe
s'agissant des quotas euh enfin
s'agissant de votre question sur la loi
immigration je vais me permettre quand
même une petite prise de position euh
effectivement euh la la mesure en tout
cas qui est celle de d'imposer une
caution à des étudiants étrangers moi je
je travaille aussi à l'université
parinentaire au Département d'études
Slav je je j'ai beaucoup d'étudiants
extracommunautaires qui viennent
justement euh d'Europe de l'Est et et de
Russie euh il est clair que cette mesure
est désastreuse sur le plan de euh sur
le plan de l'attractivité et d'ailleurs
elle me semble même très contradictoire
avec cette volonté de faire de
l'influence une une fonction stratégique
de renouer avec une stratégie nationale
d'influence il faut quand même se
rappeler ça rejoint aussi la première
question qui a été posée que le soft
power fait partie des stratégies
d'influence les stratégies d'influence
c'est pas que créer des des comptes
inauthentiques sur les réseaux sociaux
agir comme ça non c'est c'est c'est même
d'ailleurs assez je dirais assez
marginal par rapport à la diplomatie
culturelle au liens diasporique à à
cette ce rayonnement qui est l'une des
principales forces d'ailleurs de de de
la de la France à à l'étranger et côté
russe pour vous donner quelques chiffres
on a entre 4 et 7000 étudiants africains
qui étudient dans les universités russes
qui est beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
qu'en France mais on voit depuis 4 ou 5
ans une politique d'augmentation des
quotas de la part de l'agence fédérale
rosatest qui s'occupe de qui s'occupe de
ça par exemple vis-à-vis du Mali vous
avez eu il y a l'an dernier une
augmentation de 105 enfin 150 places en
plus pour des étudiants maliens qui
viendraient étudier en Russie mais c'est
le cas aussi pour d'autres pour d'autres
pays
euh voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire les
volumes que vous présentez restent
néanmoins desis on parle de quelques
minut et surtout par rapport à l'époque
soviétique voilà pour le groupe les
républicains la parole est à Jean-Louis
tiot merci monsieur le Président le soft
power pour nous est évidemment essentiel
et par conséquent
ce rayonnement à travers les échanges
universitaires ont leur importance nous
avons voté sans aucun état d'âme puisque
visiblement le sujet du vote
d'hier occupe beaucoup cette commission
ce matin nous avons voté ce texte sans
état d'âme pour une raison extrêmement
simple en France par rapport à d'autres
pays on sait bien que dans les
coopérations universitaires on en a
certains qui sont pour avoir des
formations et puis on en a d'autres
notamment dans des secteurs où l'emploi
est assez limité je pense sociologie et
autres activités de ce genre où ce sont
des filières parallèles d'immigration en
revanche en revanche je pense
profondément que la coopération
universitaire est vitale on sait très
bien ce que font certains pays je pense
aux américains avec le programme young
leader par exemple qui n'en est que la
la tête de gondol mais ont la capacité
d'identifier des élites qui le lendemain
sont des relais d'influence donc ce que
je souhaiterais savoir et ma question
s'adresse autant à Jonathan giffar ou à
Maxime ainet quelle est la stratégie des
Turcs ou des Russes pour sélectionner
les étudiants qu'ils accueillent dans
leurs universités au nom de notre groupe
je peux vous dire une chose c'est qu'
accueillir des futures élites africaines
nous le faisons et nous le faisons avec
enthousiasme simplement le système ne
doit pas être détourné donc quelle est
la stratégie d'identification des élites
dans ces deux pays
merci monsieur gufard vous souhaitez
commencer
oui je là enfin ma Ronse c'est que je
clairement je elle est pas différente de
la nôtre il il y a pas une spécificité
dans la sélection des élites et quelque
enfin dans la sélection quelque part des
étudiants et euh pour aller vers les
élites à partir du moment où c'est un
processus relativement similaire au are
sur le plan bilatéral c'est-à-dire d'une
discussion d'état à état la sélection se
fait en partie par l'État partenaire
donc effectivement vous aurez plus
souvent des gens issus de l'élite
euh ça c'est une première chose en
revanche la comment dire ça le la la
pénétration on va dire du tissu social à
différents niveaux notamment par les ONG
turques religieuses ou non
d'ailleurs notamment par les fameux
syndicats patronaux de travailleurs dont
je parlais permettent d'identifier aussi
des partenaires à faire venir dans ce
cadre là et vous avez la formation des
imams par exemple vous avez aussi des
gens qui rejoignent ces ONG sur un et
qui vont qui sont des je veux dire des
personnels enfin qui sont des gens des
Africains pardon et qui viennent du coup
travailler avec avec ces organisations
et donc ils viennent aussi en Turquie
pour se faire former donc ça se joue à
plusieurs
niveaux sur la partie d'une éventuelle
sélection sur la partie universitaire je
sais pas si pe Charon ou Maximin vous
avez un point complémentaire
maximinet il y a un programme de young
leaders russe qui s'appelle nov pacalien
nouvelle génération qui s'appuie qui
s'appuie un peu sur le même modèle que
les young leaders
américains qui sélectionnent
effectivement avec un intérêt euh
relativement opportuniste qui d'ailleurs
en soi n'est pas à mon avis un modèle
qu'il faut nécessairement valoriser je
veux dire on n'est pas obligé de créer
un un un programme de ce type dans
l'hypothèse que la personne qu'on va
faire venir sera un futur ministre dans
un pays africain afin deser ça ne peut
pas être que fondé sur ça c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que l'université joue
un rôle essentiel dans ce domaine et que
parfois on ne sait pas ce que ces gens
vont devenir enfin moi en tout cas j'ai
jamais vu pour j'aimerais bien avoir
quelques chiffres mais j'ai jamais vu
dans meses départements des gens qui
étaient uniquement là pour pour obtenir
des permis de séjour mais dans le casre
de la Russie oui vous avez par exemple
des programmes très intenses avec des
journalistes qui sont qui sont mis en
œuvre notamment vis-à-vis de l'Afrique
où vous avez chaque année des dizaines
de journalistes qui travaillent dans des
rédactions de de de médias africains qui
soit vont à Moscou RT spoutnic par
exemple ont mis en place des des
programmes qui sont d'ailleurs liés à
novoaupac Alien qui s'appelle la R t
School et sputnic pro qui accueille des
journalistes et qui les forment si vous
voulez au standards ou aux normes
journalistiques qui sont celles partagé
par ces médias c'est-à-dire une vision
très conflictuelle de l'espace
informationnel un engagement très
contrehégémonique et et ensuite
effectivement ces journalistes repartent
dans leur rédaction et on peut imaginer
qu'ensuite ce tissent des liens avec ces
médias c'est comme ça que ça c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne aussi ah Monsieur
char je vous en pris mais juste de mots
pour pour dire qu'on a à peu près le
même mécanisme en Chine il y a il y a y
a un mécanisme de young leaders il y a
il y a d'autres programmes d'ailleurs de
que les Chinois ont pu appeler 1000
talents par exemple pour identifier
justement les les les talents à
l'étranger qu'il faudrait faire venir
travailler en en Chine euh donc ça suit
à peu près les les les mêmes processus
et mêmes dispositifs que que qu'en
Russie
euh mais une stratégie d'influence c'est
pas seulement les élites euh donc les
Chinois bien sûr visent les élites mais
il visent aussi les masses et et les
masses et ben ça passe par d'autres par
d'autres mécanismes d'autres dispositifs
mais ils sont capables de faire les deux
donc si on songe un petit peu à la
stratégie d'influence de la France il
faut aussi être capable d'attirer les
élites mais aussi de toucher les
masses merci pour le groupe démocrate la
parole est à Jean-Pierre Cubertafon
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues messieurs nous avons depuis
plusieurs semaines engagé au sein de la
commission de la Défense nationale un
travail important sur la question de
l'influence de la stratégie et de la
place de la France sur le continent
africain je tiens à vous remercier au
nom du groupe démocrate de votre
présence ce jour afin de pouvoir
échanger autour de la stratégie de nos
compétiteurs en Afrique et j'aimerais
aujourd'hui me concentrer sur le sujet
russe c'est la raison pour laquelle je
m'adresserai tout particulièrement à
monsieur odinet nous savons tous que la
Russie principalement autour du groupe
paramilitaire Wagner a vu son influence
fortement grandir ces dernières années
en Afrique vous en avez parlé l'un des
principaux objectifs de la Russie en
Afrique est d'acquérir une influence sur
les territoires stratégiques le long de
la Méditerranée méridionale et de la Mer
Rouge monsieur odinet pensez-vous
aujourd'hui que la Russie soit parvenu à
cet objectif et un deuxième objectif
serait bien évidemment de supplanter
l'influence occidentale et je pense ici
notamment à la République centrafricaine
ou au mali parfois par des méthodes non
officielles comme l'ingérence ou la
désinformation
quelle évolution observons-nous sur le
continent africain en ce qui concerne
les différents gouvernements africains
vis-à-vis de la Russie et quelle
implication pour le la gouvernance et la
stabilité en Afrique envisagez-vous au
regard de l'investissement russe sur ce
continent je vous remercie maximood vous
avez la
parole alors comment vous répondre en 3
minutes sur sur je vais je vous répondre
peut-être sur les sujets que je
maîtrise donc s'agissant de des
objectifs que vous avez énoncé euh alors
ils sont en partie réalisés euh moi je
je travaillant maintenant sur sur cette
présence russe en Afrique depuis à peu
près 3 ans j'ai encore souvenir de de
certaines réflexions disant que
finalement les Russes vont se casser les
dents et cetera bon c'est en partie vrai
c'est en partie pas vrai notamment par
exemple au Mali je crois que la prise de
Kidal quand bien même sera-t-elle
maintenue ça c'est je pense que Jonathan
aura beaucoup de de choses à dire sur la
question mais le fait est quand même que
au moins sur le plan symbolique euh et
et donc sur le plan politique la Russie
a obtenu a réussi à à obtenir des
dividendes absolument considérables
depuis depuis maintenant fin 2017-28 et
le fait est que si même aujourd'hui on
parle de de de la Russie à ce point en
Afrique c'est bien c'est bien une une
réussite qui d'ailleurs c'est bien que
vous ayez rappelé aussi l'Afrique du
Nord puisquon parle beaucoup de du Sahel
mais la présence russe en Afrique est
extrêmement importante en Afrique du
Nord évidemment en Libye mais les deux
euh sur les trois disons partenaires
stratégiques de de de de la Russie en
Afrique deux sont en Afrique du Nord
puisqu'il s'agit de l'Algérie et de
l'Égypte qui ont des liens beaucoup plus
anciens avec avec l'Afrique qui sont des
partenaires économiques majeurs
notamment dans la
coopération la coopération militaire et
et la vente d'armement
euh donc donc voilà et et s'agissant du
Sahel effectivement on voit très bien
que aujourd'hui euh notamment avec cette
initiative dont j'ai oublié le nom mis
en place par les trois pays sahéliens la
es voilà exactement on voit on voit bien
à quel point la Russie via d'ailleurs sa
présence officielle ce qu' est encore
est une une mutation importante et et
qui va être évidemment utilisé aussi par
le pouvoir russe pour pour assoir cette
cette capacité et cette projection de
puissance sur des terrains qui sont
éloignés de sa de son voisinage direct
comme ça a été le cas auparavant en
Syrie mais on voit bien que la Russie
essaie de de devenir une je dirais un
prestataire d'offre politique
sécuritaire militaire
informationnel et que c'est un un un
forcé de constater que c'est un système
qui fonctionne qui s'exporte aujourd'hui
on voit que le Niger même si l'influence
américaine est beaucoup plus importante
que que dans d'autres pays israéliens
est un pays qui semble hésiter justement
pour aller vers ce terrain le Burkina
Faso est en train de de de totalement
tourner vers vers ce type de de
coopération donc donc c'est un modèle
attractif de ce point de vue c'est
peut-être dur à à entendre mais c'est un
modèle qui est attractif pour en tout
cas des des gouvernements qui sont issus
de de Poch ou qui défendent un agenda je
dirais néosouverainiste pour reprendre
pour reprendre sur le plan idéologique
des notions qui sont qui sont bien
travaillées par des des chercheurs
africains donc donc voilà voilà ce qu'on
peut dire sur ce sujet c'est une
tendance lourde tendance lourde puisque
elle est présente au sein des sociétés
africaines on est face à des phénomènes
endogènes sur lesquels je le rappelle la
Russie s'appuie c'est pas la Russie qui
qui est à l'origine de de de ce genre
d'asscise et de socle qui lui permettent
de se déployer merci pour le groupe
socialiste la parole est à Valérie Rabo
ou merci monsieur le
Président moi j'aurais deux questions la
première porte donc vous avez abordé la
question des étudiants la première porte
sur les cabinets ministériels qui
existent dans les différents
gouvernements il y avait beaucoup de
Français précédemment maintenant on
parle anglais euh donc c'est pas tout à
fait la stratégie russe et haute mais
est-ce que vous voyez une stratégie
d'approche très offensive mené par les
différents pays les États-Unis l'ont
mené est-ce que au détriment de la
France he au maintenant il y a quasiment
beaucoup moins de je crois qu'il y en a
même quasiment plus ça c'est la première
question la deuxième porte sur la
stratégie militaire il me semble
saufireur de ma part qu'il y avait dans
les formations de l'OTAN un certain
nombre de places réservées
pour des officiers africains euh de ce
que je comprends ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui ça a un peu basculé plutôt
vers une stratégie vis-à-vis du
Moyen-Orient et du Proche-Orient est-ce
que vous confirmez cela et est-ce que
dans le fond sur la question de la
formation des officiers africains on
observe que le les places qui leur
étaient réservé au sein de l'OTAN
n'existent plus et ont été attribués à
d'autres et dans ce cas est-ce que
d'autres pays euh ont pris la relève
c'est-à-dire assure des formations
d'officiers africains
merci qui souhaite commencer
Maxim monsieur guffard je vous en prie
alors je vais essayer de répondre au
enfin pour ma part aux deux en même
temps parce que c'est un sujet qui est
lié s'agissant de de de cette offensive
dont vous avez parlé sur les cabinets
mais de manière général effectivement
sur sur l'élite politique on en a
effectivement un peu parlé euh les
Américains on n pas parlé des Américains
et c'est vrai que les Américains sont
très offensifs dans le domaine mais ça
c'est un point important
l'administration Biden a mis en place
des nouvelles stratégies très vocales
fait beaucoup de déplacements et met du
poids politique dans cette stratégie en
revanche mais très peu de moyens et en
fait ça ne change pas donc l'Afrique
n'est pas beaucoup plus une priorité à
Washington qu'elle ne l'était avant en
revanche donc l'attractivité
effectivement dans on parlait c'était un
peu le débat tout à l'heure c'est c'est
une attractivité en soi culturelle et
effectivement les gens se tournent vers
l'anglais c'est vrai en Afrique
sub-saharienne c'est vrai au Maghreb
c'est particulièrement vrai au Maghreb
au Maroc les gens ils apprennent
l'anglais ils apprennent plus MOS le
français dans leurs études euh et et la
Turquie enfin on en a parlé mène cette
politique d'influence vers les élites
politiques pour ce qui est de la
stratégie militaire je saurais pas vous
répondre sur la partie utanienne pure et
dure en revanche euh
la France continue de faire de la
formation des officiers ça c'est certain
les États-Unis le font beaucoup mais les
États-Unis le font beaucoup parce que
plusieurs pays sont on va dire empêtrés
dans des crises de lutte contre le
terrorisme et donc depuis 10 ou 20 ans
sont en contact des Américains certains
des Français ou d'autres et donc ont une
formation très importante vous avez dû
entendre parler au moment des PCH au
Sahel ici ou là on se disait tiens eux
ont été formés par les Américains à un
moment de leur carrière c'estra vrai les
Turcs ont beaucoup investi le champ de
la formation mais en fait cette
formation donnée par les Turcs c'est
particulièrement vrai en Libye c'est
particulièrement vrai en Somalie mais a
aussi noué un certain nombre d'accords
de défense peut-être une trentaine enfin
avec une trentaine de pays en Afrique il
y a toujours un volet formation sauf que
la Turquie est une armée formée au
standard autant et par exemple je pense
que les Américains sont très contents
que ça soit les Turcs qui s'occupent de
former un certain nombre de ses
partenaires au standard autant sans
prendre en compte la dimension
d'influence de cette partie de la
formation et enfin j'aimeris insister
sur un point parce que c'est lié à votre
question c'est important
eu le UTM par exemple donc la la la
mission de formation qui a eu au Mali
des Fas a duré très longtemps quand vous
parler aux officiers Famin aujourd'hui
la plupart vous disent que ça n'a pas
servi beaucoup la formation qui a été
dispensée par Barc a beaucoup plus
fonctionner que lesutm pour des simples
raisons organisationnelles ou parce que
c'est une opération EUR vous avez des
officiers qui ont dit avoir reçu sur
l'espace de je sais pas un mois de
formation une formation avec une
quinzaine de pays différents avec des
gens qui parlent français d'autres qui
ne parlaient pas français des gens qui
étaient formés à tel aspect ou tel
aspect bref ça rend les choses
extrêmement compliqué la formation en
multi donc je sais pour la parti autant
je suis je sais pas si ça a lieu je suis
pas certain que ça un impact quelconque
en terme de formation le bilatéral ça
fonctionne quand même beaucoup mieux
Maxim sur extrêmement rapidement sur je
pourrais pas répondre à votre deème
question mais sur la la des cabinets
ministériel en tout cas oui on a
observé une tentative par au-delà du de
cette pénétration des espaces
médiatiques et informationnels dont dont
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure il y a aussi
une tentative de effectivement de de
noyutage dans le dans la sphère
politique qu'on a bien vu en RCA qui en
fait objectivement est le le lieu où ce
noyotage a été le le plus poussé
puisqu'on a des conseillers russes qui
étaient directement euh je dirais des
conseillers du président toisera avec
une capacité d'influence extrêmement
forte avec l'installation aussi et ça
c'est vraiment Wagner l'installation
d'une d'une espèce de protoousine à
troll qu'on appelait le Bureau
Information et
communication qui permettait à la fois
et qui était rattaché à la présidence
coordonné par par Wagner et qui
permettait et d'ailleurs qui existe
probablement toujours hein peut-être
sous une nouvelle forme c'est assez
difficile de de de d'estimer mais qui
permettait à la fois de légitimer
Wagner en République centrafricaine et
puis dans la région puisque c'était une
une espèce de base pour pour voilà pour
la promotion d'opération
informationnelle mais aussi qui
permettait de légitimer le président
toadera son son parti politique
mouvement cœursuni qui a qui a été
activé pendant pendant les échéances
électorales donc on voit très bien
comment vous avez une espèce de je
dirais de de convergence d'intérêt entre
acteurs R russe et acteurs locaux c'est
un petit peu ce que j'expliquais tout à
l'heure avec cette idée des acteurs
tiers euh et qui concerne aussi la
sphère politique et d'ailleurs je juste
pour pour rebondir on l'a vu un petit
peu aussi au Burkina c'est intéressant
de voir à quel point pour un certain
nombre d'élit politiques africaines le
fait même euh de euh de d'utiliser dans
leur discours politique une une volonté
de rapprochement et de coopération
accrue avec la Russie est un gage pour
eux de de gain et de capital politique
c'est-à-dire que ça permet à peu de
frais finalement d'afficher une
opposition euh à euh à cette euh voilà à
cette à la présence française et ça
permet de tirer un certain nombre de
gains et ça c'est très euh ça ça c'est
un levier par lesquel justement les
acteurs russes euh cherchent à euh
justement à s'implanter à noyoter des
structures politiques dans ces pays Paul
Charon vous avez un Moot à
dire je crois que le la la le tour de la
question a été a été fait je j'ai pas de
réponse non plus sur le sur l'OT temp
malheureusement euh je dirais simplement
que les Chinois eux aussi offrent de
nombreuses formations aux officiers
africains j'ai pas j'ai pas les chiffres
en tête euh mais c'est assez important
et et ça couvre l'ensemble du continent
euh donc ça se substitue pas bien sûr
parce que la France continue de le faire
d'autres pays européens continuent de le
faire les Américains le font beaucoup ça
a été dit mais les chinois ils prennent
part aussi et bien évidemment parce que
c'est un levier d'influence bien
identifié par les par les Chinois qui
peut se traduire d'ailleurs ensuite
euh par par des influence en matière de
de de vente d'armes ou autres on en a
pas parlé mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
un enjeu pour les Chinois même s'ils
sont plutôt sur un segment d'armes
légère et de de qualité disons
relativement moyenne sur le continent
africain merci pour le groupe horiz
pardon je vous en prie Jath non pardon
juste une idée complémentaire ça vient
de m'y faire penser mais il y a une
chose qui est quand même important
important c'est que il faut quand même
faire la distinction entre les officiers
qu'on va former et le fait que d'une
manière ou d'une autre ils seront
favorables à une politique française ou
autre plus tard encore une fois les gens
qui ont fait des PCH au Sahel ont tous
été formés de près ou de loin par les
Français ou les Américains donc après la
situation change à un moment T et c'est
important en revanche ce qui a souvent
été souligné dans le débat au moment des
des PCH ça été de dire plus vous avez
des gens quel que parformmer avec qui
vous discutez plus vous avez une manière
de l'anticiper et il y a tout un sujet
autour de la remontée d'information mais
en mais pas du l'alignement
politique pour la dernière intervention
de groupe pour le groupe horizon la la
parole est à loï carvan et nous aurons
deux questions complémentaires à ce
stade merci monsieur le Président
d'abord au nom du groupe horizon
remercier nos nos trois intervenant
aujourd'hui dire aussi que nous ne
partageons pas certains propos qui ont
pu être tenus par d'autres groupes sur
la perte d'influence de la France en
Afrique nous croyons que la la situation
est beaucoup plus complexe et que not
notamment sur l'Afrique non francophone
il se passe aussi des choses où au
contraire la France gagne du terrain et
nous pensons comme sur la colonisation
qu'il faut être vigilant pour ne pas
intégrer justement des
discours qui se déploient ailleurs dans
le cadre d'une d'une vraie stratégie
informationnelle vos présentations
étaient très clair sur chacun de ces
acteurs et donc mes questions elles se
situent plutôt sur les intersections les
hiérarchies et cetera donc j'ai un prier
groupe de de questions autour de de
cette question des des hiérarchies
finalement entre ces trois acteurs
est-ce que lequel est le plus influent
et est-ce qu'il y a des différences
d'influence
importantes en Afrique pour voilà
remettre tout ça un peu en contexte un
peu dans la ligée de mon collègue
saintou aussi par rapport à d'autres
acteurs sur le continent et notamment
les États-Unis est-ce qu'on est sur des
influences finalement qui si on regarde
l'ensemble sont sont vraiment très
faibles et anecdotiques où est-ce que ce
sont on a maintenant pour les les trois
états qu'on a étudié des États qui se
portent à des niveaux d'influence
réellement significatif et puis monsieur
Giffard l'a bien fait pour la Turquie en
replaçant aussi l'intérêt de l'Afrique
pour la Turquie par rapport à d'autres
zones du monde et vous avez cité les
Balcans par exemple est-ce qu'on peut
faire un peu la même chose pour pour la
Chine et la Russie ça c'était la
hiérarchie les motivation rapidement euh
on a pu évoquer dans d'autres auditions
que finalement pour résumer de manière
un peu abrupte peut-être la Russie
cherchait plus le chaos ailleurs
que et la Chine plus la prédation sur
place et tous Peut-être l'affermissement
de leur pouvoir et de leur légitimité
dans leur pays est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est quelque chose ou est-ce qu'il
y a de différences aussi d'autres
différences plus fondamentales et enfin
sur les moyens moi je suis frappé au
Liban par exemple pour la Turquie de la
présence de la Turquie via des produits
très peu chers notamment dans un
contexte d'inflation et des
commerçants est-ce que c'est vous l'avez
évoqué un petit peu ça se devinait à
travers ce que vous avez dit sur
l'exportation et cetera est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui qui est fort aussi en
Afrique est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que par exemple la Chine utilise parce
que on se dit qu'elle a aussi cette
capacité là je vous
remercie on peut commencer par la
Turquie si vous le souhaitez Jonathan
guffard alors pour répondre sur la
hiérarchie je je je prétendrais pas
hiérarchie enfin moi je vais je vais pas
le faire mais très clairement
actuellement
le si vous prenez vous parlez de
dynamique politique pour moi la
dynamique politique la Russie est très
largement devant par rapport à la
Turquie et de manière générale sur
l'empreinte en terme économique la Chine
est tout à fait devant par rapport à la
Turquie c'est important de la voir c'est
pour ça que j'ai souligné tout à l'heure
que ce qui les distingue en revanche
c'est que la Turquie est la seule à
pouvoir jouer la carte de l'Islam et de
la culture et ça c'est important parce
que c'est c'est c'est plus subtile c'est
plus pérenne et c'est plus stable de
manière général ça sera des imams turces
qui viendront euh offrir faire des dons
pendant laïde ça sera pas des Chinois ou
des Russes bon bah ça ça structure des
pays entiers donc c'est c'est quand même
important sur cette un un autre point
quand même de tension qui existe c'est
sur les théâtres c'est-à-dire que on a
beaucoup parler euh de la connivance et
de cette espèce de compétition par la
coopération entre Erdogan et et Poutine
euh il y a il y a un aspect coopération
et un aspect compétition et la Libye
c'est un terrain de compétition très
fort où ni l'un ni l'autre d'ailleurs ne
prend l'avantage d'une manière ou d'une
autre
eu c'est ça c'est c'est un point
important parce qu'effectivement il y a
plusieurs endroits où vous allez
observer réapparaître cette compétition
et quand ça les arrange les Turcs qui
sont très proches des Russes dans leur
discours et quand ça les arrange les
Turcs c'est le bouclier de l'OTAN et ça
marche à peu près tout le temps pour eux
donc ça c'est important euh pour les
motivations j'en ai parlé je laisserai
mes collègues parler pour pour eux pour
les moyens oui vous enfin oui oui vous
vous avez raison c'est c'est c'est pour
ça que je parlais d'économie d'export
c'est important de garder ça en tête
c'est c'est enfin toutes les la Chine la
première mais la France enfin tous les
pays pensent aussi l'exportation de
leurs produits eux se positionnent sur
des gammes importantes d'exportation de
produits manufacturés beaucoup de de
produits de consommation courante euh et
il faut pour bien comprendre il faut le
voir que avant la la crise économique de
2018 en gros toute la croissance de la
Turquie entre 2001 2002 et sur le plan
économique j'entends et 2018 avant que
ça se crache c'est une économie qui est
au centre des chaînes
d'approvisionnement donc qui prend que
des
produits qui les transforme qui a une
base industrielle très importante et qui
les exporte en Europe bon ben comme il y
a maintenant il y a un problème ils
veulent un produire plus même de
produits de faible valeur ajoutée et les
exporter sauf que c'est plus simple du
coup de les exporter en Afrique en
Europe parce que la compétition n'est
pas la même donc oui et cette présence
enfin je je je pense que c'est vraiment
important de le noter parce que c'est
c'est un peu c'est un peu le cliché de
des machines à lavé allemandes un peu
partout pendant longtemps mais c'est un
peu la même chose quelque part dans les
cuisines partout vous avez du archeliic
archelic c'est l'équivalent de Bosch si
je ne me Tromp pas turque effectivement
très bien Paul chon pour la Chine oui
merci alors sur sur la hiérarchie euh je
crois que je je suis assez d'accord euh
sans doute la Chine domine très
largement sur le plan économique à la
fois les acteurs Russes et les acteurs
Turcs euh c'est évident et c'est lié
déjà à leur très forte présence
économique sur le continent africain et
puis à l'étendue de leur moyens alors ça
pourrait changer dans les années à venir
on voit déjà une inflexion euh des
programmes qui intègrent les routes de
la soie la BRI on voit qu'il y a une
diminution des investissements chinois
il y a un retrait sur un certain nombre
de projets le continent africain sera
impacté également mais malgré ça on est
à des annéeslumières de ce que peuvent
faire les les Russes ou les Turcs donc
bien évidemment sur le plan économique
il domine très largement pour le reste
la présence chinoise est nous sommes
toutes modéré enfin sur le plan
sécuritaire si on on exclut la base de
Djibouti c'est c'est très faible il y a
quelques SMP chinoises mais euh qui font
exclusivement du gardienage de sociétés
chinoises pour l'instant c'est c'est
surtout ça il y a toujours une volonté
d'ouvrir une base à l'ouest
potentiellement ou pas il y a plusieurs
projets qui sont prêtés à la Chine mais
on pour l'instant on n pas de de de
d'élément de preuve fort voilà qui
permettrait de de de confirmer cette
hypothèse il y a d'autres hypothèses en
océan Indien dans l'océan Pacifique euh
donc on verra mais mais ça ça fait
partie bien évidemment de voilà des
projets à moyen terme
euh sur le plan sur le plan
informationnel ils font des efforts
importants mais ils sont encore encore
derrière les capacités russes euh sans
doute parce qu'ils comprennent moins
bien les écosystèmes locaux
euh ce qui fait qu'ils insistent
beaucoup sur ce qui se passe en Chine
sur leur réussite euh sur le le fait de
développer de proposer une une image
positive de la Chine mais qui sont moins
capables d'instrumentaliser les
problématiques locales ils le font de
plus en plus mais mais il ils ont ils
ont pas atteint la la la capacité des
Russes en la
matière par ailleurs il faut souligner
peut-être et ça on le fait pas assez
souvent Maxime l'a dit pour la Russie
c'est vrai pour la Chine aussi on n pas
à faaire à à un seul
acteur on on se représente souvent les
régimes autoritaires comme des régimes
extrêmement centralisés où il y a un
seul acteur ou même s'ils sont plusieurs
ils sont très disciplinés et obéissent
aux ordre qui vient du pouvoir central
la Chine fonctionne absolument pas comme
ça déjà il y a une multitude d'acteurs
avec des Red tondance multiples euh pour
une politique publique vous allez avoir
parfois 15 20 30 agences susceptibles
d'intervenir sur dans ce champ-l et ils
sont elles sont en compétition les unes
avec les autres euh il y a pas du tout
de coordination sur le terrain et c'est
parfois le le le chaos euh donc dans le
cas chinois c'est très très frappant sur
le plan informationnel c'est c'est c'est
évident et c'est vrai dans dans d'autres
champs aussi
euh et c'est vrai aussi sur le
économique c'est-à-dire que la
domination économique aujourd'hui de la
Chine en Afrique euh elle est pas liée à
un vaste plan préparé à Pékin et mis en
œuvre sur le terrain par des
acteurs disciplinés c'est
essentiellement des entrepreneurs des
petits entrepreneurs d'abord privés euh
qui ont conquis le terrain et c'est
cette présence ensuite qui est
instrumentalisée par le parti euh et les
agences gouvernementales
h l'influence alors est-ce qu'elle est
anecdotique vaste question on on manque
de de d'études sérieuses sur les sur les
réceptions des des opérations
d'influence il y a quelques études qui
soulignent que les les médias officiels
chinois en Afrique sont peu regardés peu
écoutés peu lu mais quand ils le
sont ça a un effet sur sur l'audience
donc un effet positif sur l'image perçu
de la Chine alors après il faut toujours
prendre ça avec précaution parce que
est-ce que les gens qui consultent ces
médias avaient déjà une image positive
de de la Chine ou est-ce que c'est parce
qu'ils regardent les médias qu'ils ont
meilleure image de la Chine que les
autres on sait pas
trop là où c'est plus difficile aussi
c'est que il y a les médias officiels
d'un côté mais il y a tout le reste les
faux comptes les campagne clandestine
beaucoup plus sophistiqué et cetera don
là on a beaucoup plus de mal à mesurer
l'influence mais qui qui qui peut être
loin de d'être négligeable euh l'Afrique
pour la Chine
euh c'est important et ça l' pas en même
temps si vous représentez les intérêts
de la Chine comme une succession de
cerclle concentrique à partir de de de
la Chine forcément l'Afrique c'est loin
ça compte moins que l'environnement
direct de de la Chine c'est c'est moins
important que taiïwan c'est moins
important que la que la péninsule
coréenne que le Japon que la mer de
Chine méridionale même que la présence
américaine euh dans dans dans dans dans
dans le Pacifique à proximité de la
Chine moins important peut-être même que
que l'océan Indien ou l'Asie centrale et
c'est seulement après qu'arrive
l'Afrique euh donc si on garde ça à
l'esprit oui l'Afrique c'est important
pour tout un tas de raison parce qu'il y
a de plus en plus de de citoyens chinois
en Afrique donc il faut être capable de
les protéger les Chinois ont été
traumatisés par les les printemps arabes
et leur incapacité à évacuer
correctement leurs ressortissants de
Libye notamment euh donc protection des
citoyens chinois euh légitimité de de la
Chine non seulement du régime mais aussi
en tant qu'acteur international euh d'où
le choix de Djibouti c'est Djibouti
c'est un intérêt logistique pratique
soutien aux opérations de lutte contre
la
piraterie possibilité d'intervenir en
cas de crise humanitaire et cetera mais
c'est aussi être dans la cour des grands
avoir une base là où sont aussi
implantés les Américains les Français
les Italiens japonais euh donc la la le
symbole est est puissant aussi de ce
point de vue-là euh les intérêts
économiques bien évidemment préignant
énergétique minier euh tout ça compte
beaucoup pour pour les Chinois bien sûr
et on pourrait ajouter
l'instrumentalisation des États
africains à l'ONU quand il s'agit de
faire voter
euh en soutien en soutien de la Chine on
l'a vu par exemple dans le cas de
l'Ukraine où la Russie et la Chine ont
œuvré
pour que les États africains au minimum
s'abstiennent ou refusent les les
sanctions contre la Russie
[Musique]
euh est-ce qu'il y a une prédation
oui et non enfin c'est toujours pareil
c'est pas forcément la Chine n arrive
pas en Afrique en se disant qu'elle va
avoir une attitude de de prédateur mais
par contre il font du business et
parfois ça a des conséquences négatives
sur sur les acteurs locaux d'autant que
les Chinois ont tendance ça c'est c'est
très bien documenté donc je m'étends pas
là-dessus mais on tendance à à proposer
des packs complets aux acteurs locaux
euh donc il y a un projet
d'infrastructure qui est signé avec un
État africain mais ça implique que c'est
des sociétés chinoises qui vont euh
participer ou assurer la construction de
ces infrastructures avec des ouvriers
chinois qui viennent s'installent là ont
assez peu de contact avec les les euh
les sociétés locales et cetera bon tout
ça c'est c'est assez bien documenté ce
qui peut donner le sentiment d'une
prédation un petit peu plus plus
prononcée et puis les moyens euh oui
donc ils inondent les marchés africain
de produits peu chers à très bas coût et
les marchés locaux sont incapables de
enfin les producteurs locaux sont
incapables de rivaliser euh et là pareil
c'est pas forcément une stratégie pour
euh laminer ces ces ces sociétés ou
prendre le contrôle des des pouvoirs
politiques mais c'est simplement une
stratégie commerciale qui fonctionne
comme elle a fonctionné ailleurs
d'ailleurs
et enfin maximinet
oui alors pour pour votre première
question je rejoins ce que ce qu'on dit
mes mes collègues
euh effectivement il y a une dynamique
du côté de la Russie on sait que
l'influence elle passe énormément aussi
par je dirais des ressources symboliques
immatérielles on agit sur les
perceptions c'est bien ça le le le cœur
du sujet et très clairement il y a une
une capacité absolument euh euh
extraordinaire des acteurs russes et
notamment de Wagner à faire parler de
soi ce qui est ce qui est assez
fondamental l'un l'une des incarnations
de ça c'est le c'est ces drapau russes
qu'on voit brandir alors soit euh pour
des raisons soit de manière je dirais
authentique soit parfois de manière
inauthentique c'est-à-dire on sait bien
qu'il y a eu aussi des des campagnes
financées de C là mais le fait est que
il y a quelque chose de magnétique euh
dans cette ces symboles de la présence
russe dans un certain nombre de de pays
où dès qu'un drapeau est brandi dans une
manifestation quand bien même le sujet
de la manifestation n'a rien à voir avec
la présence russe et bien il y a ce
drapeau devient une espèce d'apau à on
voit on voit des des voilà des des
photographies de drapeau russes fleurir
sur tous les sur toute la les les les
journaux internationaux et cetera et ça
c'est quelque chose qui était vraiment
très incarné par Prigogine qui était
quelqu'un qui avait une obsession de
capital une obsession d'engendrer du
capital symbolique justement et
politique une ob session de faire parler
de soi ce qui d'ailleurs est aussi un
élément qui va devoir nous interroger
aujourd'hui c'està-dire est-ce que ces
acteurs officiels dont on sait que ils
préfèrent souvent agir de manière
beaucoup plus clandestine ou
semi-clandestine ou ou en tout cas de
manière plus plus tamisée disons est-ce
qu'ils vont avoir aussi ce genre de
voilà de de volonté de de faire parler
de même et cetera bon ce qu'on a vu
encore une fois à Kidal avec Wagner qui
a fait Isser un drapeau de Wagner sur le
fort de Kidal et cetera donc ils sont là
aussi on a des des vraiment des des des
opér de communication de ce point de vue
qui sont qui sont assez différenciés euh
je voudrais quand même remettre un petit
peu aussi en perspective cette présence
russe bon on a parlé de l'aspect
économique sans être un nain c'est pas
la Russie n'est pas un nain économique
mais aujourd'hui on est autour de voilà
20 milliards de de volume d'échange dans
le cas de la Chine je crois on est
autour de 250 milliards
euh peut-être même plus visiblement donc
donc voilà et puis dans le champ
informationnel aussi pour parler de de
de nos de nos fleurons nationaux euh RFI
et France24 qui alors certes ne sont pas
des médias d'État ce sont des médias de
services publics internationaux c'est
une différence fondamentale mais RFI et
France 24 sont
incommensurablement plus écoutés lu et
vu en Afrique subsaharienne que que ne
le sont RT sputnck aujourd'hui quand
bien même on a une dynamique d'expansion
mais qui est qui est beaucoup moins
importante que que ces médias quant aux
motivation
euh et je m'arrête là je crois que c'est
c'est intéress de au-delà évidemment des
objectifs d'affaiblissement de la
présence occidentale d'obtenir des
soutiens aussi de la part d'un certain
nombre d'États pour voter à l'assemblée
générale des nations- Unies je pense au
Mali par exemple qui est passé d'un
vote enfin d'une abstention à un vote
contre les les justement les résolutions
visant à condamner l'invasion à grande
échelle de l'Ukraine donc ça ça en fait
partie mais justement ce qui vous parliz
du chaos ailleurs ce qui est intéressant
dans le cadre de justement de de
l'Afrique subsaharienne c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'ils ont pu pu
faire ou ce qu' continue à faire
d'ailleurs en Europe aux États-Unis ou
dans d'autres pays occidentaux là au
contraire l'idée c'est de fournir une
offre de stabilité ce qui d'ailleurs la
stabilité alors quand bien même c'est
c'est pas le cas au Mali il y a c'est
absolument pas stable mais le fait est
que dans ce discours et dans cette offre
politicosécuritaire informationnelle qui
est offerte par les acteurs russes il y
a un discours sur la stabilité qui est
un discours extrêmement présent aussi en
interne Vladimir Poutine a fondé sa sa
timité en partie sur cette exigence de
stabilité qui cherche aujourd'hui à
vendre à à un certain nombre de
pays qui sont en proie justement à de
très fortes de très fortes instabilités
voilà donc ça c'est important aussi de
comprendre qu'il y a une
capacité d'adaptation de de de d'une
très forte élasticité de ce de ces
récits et et des offres politiques
russes vis-à-vis des publics qui le
cible ça c'est fondamental très bien je
vous propose de prendre les deux
dernières questions commun pour vous
puissie à la fois avoir quelques minutes
pour répondre et conclure la parole est
à Jacqueline
Maquet merci monsieur le Président merci
messieurs pour vos différents exposés
très éclairant compte tenu de
l'expansion rapide des activités
géopolitiques de la Russie de la Chine
et de la Turquie en Afrique notamment à
travers des investissement économique
substantiel des alliances militaires et
des initiatives culturelles comment
voyez-vous l'évolution de l'influence
française sur le continent bien que vous
vous ayez déjà bien fondu sur ce sujet
en analse en analysant les stratégies
multiditionnelles de ces nations quelles
seraient selon vous les approches les
plus efficases pour la France afin de
préserver ses intérêts économiques
politiques et culturels en Afrique
pourriez-vous également discuter des
implication à long terme de la présence
renforcée de ces acteurs sur la
stabilité régionale et sur les relations
franco-africaines en tenant compte des
héritages historiques et des dynamiques
actuelles il y a pas de choix pour les
intervenants je crois que la question
s'adresse à tous les trois en plus les
trois auront l'occasion de répondre la
parole est à Mélanie tomin merci
monsieur le Président messieurs merci
pour votre expertise je ne vais pas vous
reposer la question de votre avis sur
les mesures qui ont été adoptées via le
projet de loi immigration vous l'avez
déjà fait mais bien sur les conséquences
de ces mesures dans nos partenariats
humains France université garant
privilégié des liens qui nous unissent
aux pays d'Afrique à rappeler à travers
ces chef d'établissement son opposition
farouche à des mesures validées hier
soir portant une atteinte grave son leur
dire à nos traditions d'ouverture vous
avez évoqué la caution retour le risque
de n'accueillir que des étudiants riches
l'élite et non plus la masse qui sont
contraires aux liens traditionnels qui
nous unissent il y a aussi l'adoption
d'un autre amendement visant à mieux
encadrer la délivrance d'une carte de
séjour pour un étudiant prévoyant de
conditionner au caractère sérieux de ces
études alors ma question est la suivante
considérant les conditions d'accès à
l'université française restreinte et
dans un climat ambiant de rejet de la
présence française en Afrique comment et
dans quel domaine faire perdurer les
liens concrètement dans le contexte en
quoi un État africain serait-il plus
enclin à favoriser une coopération avec
la France et plus globalement accepter
l'aide de l'Agence française du
développement plutôt qu'une autre
je vous remercie merci à toutes les deux
pour ces questions messieurs il nous
reste 6 minutes vous êtes trois vous
avez donc 2 minutes chacun euh qui veut
commencer jeonathan giifard alors je
vais essayer d'être rapide pour
l'évolution française sur le continent
je pense qu'il faut distinguer plusieurs
choses et notamment plusieurs zones dans
les pays d'Afrique anglophone
l'influence français sera en expansion
et notamment à partir du moment où le
choix est désormais d'axé sur la
coopération économique et la commation
culturelle euh il y a une envie de ces
pays-là et elle elle s'observve très
clairement elle s'observve pour ce qui
est de l'Afrique
francophone je pense que les partenaires
qui travaillent avec la France
toujours sont à la fois contents de
travailler avec la France et se sent
fragile sur le plan politique donc je
vais poser ces deux points là si vous
voulez vous parliez de l'avenir proche
il faut regarder de manière très très
proche la situation au Sénégal en Côte
d'Ivoire et au Tchad ces trois endroits
où euh le compétiteur russe euh met des
moyens dès à présent pour questionner la
présence occidentale et française donc
c'est là où il se passera des choses de
manière très proche euh sur le long
terme euh j'ai tendance à croire que euh
pour ce qui est de la présence turque et
chinoise ça va pas changer à ce qui se
passe depuis 20 ans c'est c'est une
présence continue et il va falloir comme
toute relation internationale S faireve
enfin il va falloir nous-même France
entre guillemets ou européen se montrer
compétitif et d'ailleurs j'insiste sur
le sujet européen parce que euh c'est
aussi une manière peut-être de sortir de
du sujet stricto
francoafricain et de reprendre un peu de
champ euh les Européens sont très
motivés pour aller sur différents champs
qui soient militaire économique culturel
il faut les accompagner je pense et il
faut le faire avec eux h et et donc ça
relie un peu à votre deuxième question
euh moi il me semble que euh le domaine
économique est extrêmement important et
le domaine culturel est tout autant euh
et le domaine économique je dirais même
euh élargir on parlait des produits
manufacturés mais c'est-à-dire sortir
strictement euh des grandes entreprises
françaises qui n'ont pas besoin du
gouvernement pour euh gagner des marchés
sur place et qui sont très bien
installés mais plutôt aider les PME
notamment à aller sur un terrain qui
connaissent extrêmement peu et pour
lesquels ils ont des images
caricaturales euh et ça ça me paraît
important donc euh il y a plusieurs se
seeur et notamment le secteur de
l'agriculture sur lequel j'ai beaucoup
travaillé mais qui est un secteur
fondamental pour l'Afrique de l'Ouest et
pour lequel l'investissement qui soit
public ou privé est encore trop peu
important merci la parole est à Paul
Charon merci je je serai bref puisque je
je je rejoins tout à fait ce que jeathan
vient de
dire j'ajouterai que sans doute il y a
un effort maxime a
mentionneré France 4 RFI tout à l'heure
je crois qu'on a là de des joyaux qui
qui sont sans doute pas assez soutenus
euh qui dispos de très peu de moyens et
qui pourrait en avoir bien plus euh et
ce qui serait bien évidemment favorable
à bah au moins à stabiliser l'image de
la France voir à à à la renforcer et et
surtout à offrir
euh des moyens
euh pour les populations local de
s'informer ailleurs que via les médias
ou officiels ou non russes chinois ou ou
turc puisque les Turcs sont quand même
aussi actifs sur le plan informationnel
euh donc je crois qu'on a là un un
levier qui est qui est très important et
euh je suis tout tout à fait d'accord
aussi sur le le fait que on mobilise pas
assez en France le niveau européen et
c'est euh un niveau qui qui a euh
énormément d'intérêt pour nous parce que
ça permet de déjà de disposer de plus de
moyens donc de de coordonner un certain
nombre disons de moyens épart euh et
puis parce que ça peut permettre euh
d'éteindre un certain nombre de
critiques euh que nos compétiteurs
peuvent nous adresser euh dans nos les
actions menées en Afrique donc je crois
que c'est là il y a il y a il y a un
effet de levier qu'on pourrait qu'on
pourrait exploiter merci
merci maximinet pour terminer euh oui
alors peut-être sur d'abord sur la
deuxème question c'est vrai que j'ai
j'ai j'ai en partie répondu à votre à
cette question tout à l'heure mais c'est
clair que voilà je le répète il y a
c'est un signal négatif qui est envoyé
très clairement du point de vue de cette
attractivité de notre notre système d'
enfin de d'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche aussi vis-à-vis de
l'étranger c'est aussi quelque chose qui
pourrait être exploité par justement nos
nos compétiteurs quand bien même il faut
quand même rappeler que voilà la Russie
est un pays qui est beaucoup beaucoup
moins attractif en tout cas vis-à-vis
des des étudiants africains elle attire
beaucoup de d'étudiants issus de
l'espace post-soviétique mais vis-à-vis
des des étudiants africains elle est
beaucoup moins attractive encore que la
France et c'est c'est tout à notre
honneur euh et et sur la la deuxième
question alors c'est une question très
vaste peut-être moi je vais me
concentrer sur je pense que cette
politique vis-à-vis de l'Afrique elle
elle doit être aussi articulée avec
justement cette stratégie nationale
l'influence qui a été appelé de ces vux
par le par le gouvernement euh je crois
que de ce point de vue-là si je peux
juste dire quelque chose pour conclure
c'est que je pense qu'il faut dans ce
domainel disons se s'adosser à tout un
un corps aussi éthique dans le domaine
de l'influence informationnelle qui est
vraiment fondamentale de même manière
qu'il y a une éthique de la guerre il
doit y avoir aussi une une une éthique
de la lutte informationnelle et de la
guerre informationnelle il y a des
lignes rouges qu'on ne peut pas franchir
il y a des PR qu'il ne faut surtout
pas utiliser ça vaut évidemment pour la
désinformation recourir à la
désinformation de manière systématique
et désinhibé lorsque vous êtes une
démocratie libérale vous pouvez être à
peu près sûr que au mieux vous prenez un
risque politique considérable au pire le
retour de boomerang va être extrêmement
fort violence qui n'est pas le cas pour
des des régimes autoritaires qui
n'engagent pas leur responsabilité
politique dans ce genre dans ce genre
d'action mais ça vaut aussi
effectivement pour la sphère de de
l'influence médiatique plus largement
c'est-à-dire que je pense que il faut
bien comprendre que euh pour revenir à
RT à pardon à RFI et France 24 qui sont
un atout majeur de l'influence française
en en Afrique sub-saharienne en fait ce
sont vraiment des instruments de ce
qu'on appelle la diplomatie publique
c'est-à-dire aussi une des des des
médias qui ne servent pas évidemment à
promouvoir des récits produits par le
gouvernement français ni à légitimer la
présence officielle de la France mais
bien à promouvoir la France en tant que
nation un certain nombre de voilà de
positions de valeur de de de de de de de
aussi de pardon de de ressources
culturelles je pense par exemple on en a
pas parlé mais à tout le tout le réseau
des Alliances françaises des instituts
français qui participent aussi à ce
rayonnement de la présence française et
et présence française au sens le plus
large possible voilà ça c'est assez
fondamental et et ça doit être
évidemment
intégré merci à tous les trois pour
cette audition passionnante et et très
éclairante et pour votre travail au
quotidien également sur ces sujets là
bien entendu on peut conserver des
contacts en dehors de cette audition
pour creuser l'ensemble de ces sujets
mes chers collègues je vous propose de
nous retrouver dans 5 minutes pour
l'audition des acteurs du renseignement
toujours sur ce même sujet à tout de
suite